I would like to give a special thank you
to the 45th president Donald Trump and a
Supreme Court Justice picks because
affirmative action has been ruled
unconstitutional affirmative action is a
racist policy I stand firmly against it
and I'm glad to see that the correct
ruling was handed down we'll see where
this goes already these universities are
trying to find loopholes and workarounds
to keep using race as a pretext for your
admission into these schools and it's
and it's horrifying you should not be
able to use someone's race to determine
whether or not they're able to go to a
higher learning facility not that I'm a
big fan of colleges as it is but this is
an amazing ruling and we got to see how
where it goes beyond just these
universities so it should be
particularly big news so we're gonna be
talking about that quite a bit we do
have a bit of other news Donald Trump's
response to this as well as Dylan
Mulvaney addressing the Bud Light Fiasco
that's right because Bud Light will uh
will always be in the news so we'll uh
we'll talk about that but I do think the
affirmative action thing is going to be
a really really big plus there's a story
about a whole bunch of celebrities
signing up for this petition from glad
to get basically anybody who disagrees
with them banned from the internet a lot
of celebrities are signing on to this
list so we'll talk about that and uh and
a whole lot more before we get started
my friends head over to castbrew.com
click the link in the description in the
description below to buy our cast Brew
Coffee join the cast Brew Coffee Club if
you like good coffee you'll like ours
and it helps fight the commies because
we are working towards building a
parallel economy like so many other
companies that believe in American
values and meritocracy and individual
liberties uh many of these companies can
be found in the Public Square app which
I strongly recommend if you're looking
for coffee castbrew.com it is our
company so you're supporting us and
you're getting a good cup of joe we got
new flavors coming out but I recommend
look we got the dark roast Appalachian
nights it's my fav favorite and rise
with Roberto Jr the light Rose to check
them out don't forget to also go to
timcast.com click that join us button
become a member to support our work
directly and you can check out that
members only uncensored show tonight
after this show now I want to add one
quick thing after I say smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends
the air is so insanely bad out here as
it's Indescribable apparently the DC
area was rated one of the lowest air
quality uh cities in the world and today
I wake up there is a white Haze so dense
it looks cloudy on a sunny day the the
the the light that's coming through the
windows is red and you can't breathe
it's even right now difficult to breathe
indoors we had to duct tape up the vents
to make sure air is not getting in from
the outside it's really really bad and
uh I came in the studio this morning to
record my morning show and uh I couldn't
talk literally couldn't do it I was
trying to just force air out of my lungs
and I'm just like I'm gonna go lock
myself indoors at home and then just try
and uh get my voice in shape to do the
show tonight and so uh here we are and
uh doing a bit better doing a bit better
but holy crap is it bad in fact it's so
bad we got a warning about our chickens
and had to transport them out of chicken
City into a temporary holding facility
that's indoors to protect them from the
air quality which is going to be just as
bad tomorrow so I want to stress that
you know it's pretty nuts out there I
was driving back from uh grabbing lunch
normally when you're driving through
this area Blue Ridge Mountains you can
see layers of mountains off in the
distance you could not see any of them
it was just a white wall that's how bad
it is out here so anyway just to let you
know how things are going on in that
front joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Alex
brucewood's great to be back Tim thanks
for having me uh I'm Alex bruzowitz go
to dialjtrump.com and get a not guilty
shirt free my boy djt did nothing wrong
and uh it's great to be back right on
what do you do I own a political
consulting company called X strategies
uh I'm also a full-time uh Twitter troll
we have a really good time on there uh
piss off a lot of people uh but you know
it's the beauty of America right you
have the freedom of speech and you can
piss off whoever you want online right
on well we'll talk about that so thanks
for for hanging out we got Sheamus
hanging out good to have you back man my
name is Sheamus Coughlin I make cartoons
on a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we just released one today that I
think you guys are really going to like
it's called the pride month that wasn't
I think that this pride month went
abysmally for the alphabet community and
it's been entertaining to watch so I
turned it into a cartoon I think you
guys will enjoy that if you go check it
out
oh hi everyone Ian crossing here happy
to be back uh it is a Thursday evening
let's roll this thing
yeah let's get to it Tim this uh sucks
my nose hurts my mouth hurts I'm really
tired of this I'm surge.com I woke up
sneezing today it was great search I
thought you were gonna say you were
upset about affirmative action I am that
happened in South Africa in 1998 with
the ee act and I've been dealing with it
we got installed in 88-98
decision yeah of course of course well
I've been obsessed let's jump into that
story all right here's a story from
timcast.com Supreme Court finds
affirmative action unconstitutional says
School cannot consider race during
admission Chief Justice John Roberts
wrote Harvard and UNC concluded wrongly
that the Touchstone of an individual's
identity is not challenges bested uh
skills built or Lessons Learned but the
color of their skin
the Court ruled universities and
colleges cannot weigh an applicant's
race during the admissions process the
majority of the justices found
affirmative action policies unavoidable
unavoidably employ race in a negative
manner involve racial stereotyping and
lack meaningful end points we have never
permitted admissions programs to work in
that way and we will not do so today
stated the court two appeals regarding
the constitutionality of affirmative
action have been appealed to the Supreme
Court one brought by the University of
North Carolina was blocked six to three
and one brought by Harvard University
was rejected six to two Justice katanji
Brown Jackson did not vote on the ladder
the ruling released on June 29th
overturns a previous decision made in
the grudder v Bollinger in 2003 at the
time the Supreme Court found that race
could be weighed as a factor in missions
because universities had a compelling
interest in maintaining diverse campuses
the Supreme Court is right what you need
to understand very very simply is that
in order for affirmative action to work
the Assumption must be that certain
races are inherently worse than other
races which is just not true at least I
don't believe our government should be
operating that I don't believe it but I
think the left absolutely does I'm
seeing a bunch of tweets from people
on the left
the racism pouring out of these liberals
brains is insane these people are
tweeting things about like well how will
how will minorities succeed now
hard work and and and what do you mean
they always succeeded the same way so
many other immigrants who have come to
this country have succeeded by working
really hard and making a better future
for their children it's amazing isn't it
well it's incredibly infantilizing I've
talked about affirmative action in the
past I've even done that an educational
video about it and one thing I want to
mention is well the obvious clear
Injustice with affirmative action and
the thing conservatives should talk
about most loudly is is not the soft
bigotry of low expectation but the fact
that white students and Asian students
are kept from having positions that they
have merited because students who didn't
Merit those positions were given them on
the basis of their ethnic makeup it is
also true that these policies are not
good for minorities or people in these
communities so what will happen and this
is something Thomas Soules talk
throughout this is something we did a
research video on for Freedom Tunes a
while back what happens is
a black student will end up being placed
in a classroom and in a school setting
that is beyond his academic
qualifications and so he'll end up
dropping out more often because he isn't
in a classroom that actually matches
what his standardized testing scores
tell us he's going to be capable of
achieving academically so for example if
you have a black kid who could get into
a really impressive school but not
necessarily Harvard and then affirmative
action bumps him up and puts him into
Harvard the likelihood that he's going
to drop out of Harvard is greater than
the likelihood that he would have
dropped out of the institution that he
was more qualified to attend and then
he's less likely to get a degree so to
clarify while you are correct in the
context of this they're targeting
minorities what you're saying applies to
literally any person of any race if you
take any person of any race who scores
low on an entrance exam and then put
them in a more advanced program yes
they're likely to drop from that program
and so what these programs were doing
was was one they seeing the entire
admission structure on on the on the
idea that certain races just inherently
and I mean it when I say inherent the
left always tries to make the argument
that when you're talking about race or
crime stats so like you think inherently
no no
the pretext for affirmative action is
inherent because they're saying all
people they're outright saying that if
you are Asian you can't come into this
school because you scored this on this
test as if all Asians are the same so
what ends up happening is they're
Latinos and and black Americans will
score at a certain level and probably
qualify for some good schools and
they'll say put them in an Ivy League
where they struggle drop out and are
worse off for it well it's such a
strange thing if you're concerned is
that there's not enough minority
representation in Academia then what you
have to do is try to structure things so
that they're they're going through the
public school system or whatever private
school system is available to them in
such a way that they end up being
qualified to attend these institutions
you don't slap a Band-Aid over it by
pushing them into institutions that
they're not qualified to attend I think
the the problem that affirmative action
is trying to solve is is
making up for the last 150 years of the
black uh citizenry of the United States
being descended from slaves not having
access to parental education like you're
their great great grandfathers were you
know slaves and didn't have did not read
and write and then they had kids that if
the parent doesn't know how to read and
write you know education's passed down a
lot of times from the adult to the child
so they're trying to solve this I guess
he would call it a class-based issue
because these people were treated as
second-class Citizens when they were
enslaved for in 1830. so it's trying to
give these people now like push them
into the the level but I think I agree
with that you're saying that you just
can't force people into higher education
and expect them to succeed I just need
to earn it I disagree I think you're
giving too much benefit of the doubt to
these people since the 50s when we
started seeing the rise of social
programs we've seen what appears to be
something beneficial that causes harm
like Sheamus is pointing out any person
who scores low who is put into a an
advanced program will likely struggle
with it and it will cause them harm I do
not believe these people are ignorant of
that fact when they have Decades of data
to show it I think many of these people
are intentionally trying to cause harm
because they're overtly racist
absolutely and we saw all throughout
2020 that the left one wants a race war
they want to inflame uh division between
uh the races and the classes and I think
it's pretty sick and I think that
affirmative action is one of the most
racist policies that we've ever seen in
Dei and race-based hiring is also uh in
fact racist people should be hired and
accepted based on merits and not based
on ethnicity or color two examples I'll
give you Ian one there's a viral video
of two white women vandalizing a black
neighborhood and two black women come
together and say stop destroying our
neighborhood and the antifa liberal
women go no no we're doing this for you
the the far leftists would go into
minority neighborhoods and assist in the
destruction I was there in Ferguson and
I'm asking myself of why are you people
destroying this black neighborhood they
wrote there was a leftist who wrote an
article after Ferguson in defense of
looting and made the argument that they
were eluding these buildings the that
black people were looting buildings
because it was resistance to the to the
machine that was oppressing them the
reality the people who lived in the
community linked arms to protect their
businesses from outside looters so why
are these people in the media lying over
and over again about it perhaps it's
because they're overt racists who know
they're not going to be able to pull off
these things if they come out and say
hey their real plan is to hurt people
they need to act like they're doing good
don't get me wrong there probably are a
lot of dumb default liberals who think
they're doing good but I think the
people organizing this know exactly what
they're doing absolutely and you know
they're attacking uh the Supreme Court
Justices as the racist in reality the
people who support affirmative action
are the racist but it's ridiculous to
say that the Supreme Court Justices are
racist because they were appointed by
the least racist president in American
history a report by Reuters just came
out and it said that Donald J Trump is
the only living president who is not a
direct descendant of slave owners so
Obama's a direct descendant of slave
owners Joe Biden's a direct descendant
of slave owners uh Jimmy Carter the
bushes Donald Trump appointed the
Supreme Court Justices who helped
overturn Roe v Wade therefore they are
the least racist Supreme Court justices
in America in my opinion and possibly
you know in Rhoda's opinion as well I
saw this story I met this uh black dude
who was anti-trump and we were having
this discussion this was in New York and
he said Donald Trump is the least racist
president this country has ever had and
I was like oh that's an interesting
thing to say aren't you against Trump
and he's like yeah yeah look Trump's
still racist but you gotta admit he's
the least racist president and then I
was like well elaborate he goes yo
president's own slaves and I was like
Fair Point fair point so his his point
was Trump is better than we've ever seen
but there's still work to be done and
I'm kind of like okay he was chill about
it you know I can respect that well he
shared the Reuters report day Trump did
that was hilarious yeah no I I thought
it was hilarious I think it's like
obviously a funny way to troll one thing
that I found very entertaining is the
reaction from a lot of democratic
politicians with affirmative action
being overturned by the court so Gavin
Newsom says they want to whitewash our
nation's history they want to bring back
to the they want to bring America back
to the era of book Bannings and
segregated campuses we cannot let them
AOC well first I'll read you uh
Elizabeth Warren she said an extremist
Supreme Court has once again reversed
Decades of settled law and she goes on
to Bellow a bit more and then my
personal favorite AOC said if scotus was
serious about their ludicrous color
blindness claims they would have
abolished legacy admissions AKA
affirmative action for the privileged 70
of Harvard's Legacy applicants are white
scotus didn't touch that which would
have impacted them and their patrons I
don't even know where to begin with that
AOC the court was not deciding on legacy
admissions at universities
well Viva fry makes a good point with
the top comment saying 71 of America is
white silly yeah so it's actually an
underrepresentation at Harvard that's
also a very good point but to say well
the Supreme a the Supreme Court didn't
touch that and then also with something
no one expected them to touch that
wasn't on the table and then it would
have impacted them and their patrons as
if the Supreme Court is unelected people
are making these decisions because uh
they're they're like bought and sold to
make this decision that's why that why
um they they decided to overturn
affirmative action but didn't say Legacy
applicants or Legacy applicants so these
are people whose children parents went
to the university yeah well it's
important to remember that Elizabeth
Warren lied about being Native American
to get hired at Harvard which propelled
her to you take that back yes that's not
true she is one one thousand twenty
fourth Native American I believe well of
course of course she's defending
affirmative action because you know she
game the system to again I know at job
at Harvard and then become ultimately a
U.S senator and so but what was it she
was actually one one thousand yeah
something like I'm sorry please don't
sue me Elizabeth you are Native American
one 1024. well no no oh no but here's
what we can say here's what we can say
the Cherokee Nation told her she could
not call herself Cherokee because what
happened was she got this blood test
back that shown showed that she was a
very very very tiny fraction Native
American and she said see this means I'm
Cherokee that's like saying well my DNA
test said that I have European blood in
me therefore I'm Italian what are you
talking about that's a much more
specific claim right but she's like like
yeah but so she's pointing to a specific
tribe and saying I have indigenous
American DNA therefore I can claim
membership in this tribe that's not how
it works but it's more than that it's
like saying I have European ancestry
therefore I'm a British citizen exactly
that's right yes no yes no yes yeah I'm
a British citizen my DNA test uh said
that I Time 1 1000th British so I guess
I'm a citizen now and the Cherokee
Nation was like no no thank you I can't
believe she tried to pull that off but
if she wants to Trump shoulder is what
happens what's what's hilarious is that
Elizabeth Warren is partially
responsible for restarting a national
conversation about why affirmative
action is bad uh you know as president
Trump started calling her Pocahontas
right and everybody's like why is she
calling her Pocahontas well she lied
about her race and ethnicity to get into
uh get a job at a school and there was a
CNN interview that I shared this morning
it was from 2017 where an admissions
consultant uh was debating why we need
to ban affirmative action and he
predicted in 2017 that President Donald
Trump will be the president to end it
he's going to use the justice department
to sue these schools which he did he
sued Yale uh and then he also said he's
gonna appoint three constitutional
conservative justices who will uh
overturn affirmative action and so that
guy on CNN was a was a prophet and so
but thank you Elizabeth Warren because
she also deserves some credit in
overturning affirmative action due to
being exposed as a liar look at the New
York Times wrote they said breaking the
Supreme Court rejected affirmative
action affirmative action as Harvard at
Harvard and UNC the major ruling
curtails race race conscious College
admissions in the U.S all but ensuring
that Elite institutions become whiter
and more Asian and less black this is
what I want to talk about in a whatever
my goodness because what I'm going to
say might come off as a defensive
affirmative action I used to hate that
when I first learned about it in 1993 we
were teenagers in high school we would
sit around talking like wait if I apply
for a job and I have a better score
they're going to hire a black guy that's
not as good as me and they're like yeah
my friends are like yeah we're like
that's Reverse Racism which turns out
years later we start to realize it's
actually just racism why don't I get in
but okay here's the situation there's a
hundred of us us we all live on a city
block uh us and 100 years ago super
racist the black people weren't allowed
to go to school they were kept as slaves
so their kids didn't have access to
education they had really crappy food
really small the their brains didn't
develop as much as they had poor
nutrition now 30 40 50 years later their
kids same thing they didn't have a lot
of access to food nutrition now it's
today and they're like we're going to
hire the smartest people on the Block
well it's the people that have
ancestrally the best access to nutrition
and education that are going to be
considered the best at and so naturally
to people with the most the healthiest
ancestors are going to get the crack at
it and what they're trying to do is to
balance it out so like sorry your
ancestors didn't have access to
education but but that's like the fairy
tale version of what they're doing which
is not what they're doing they're
hitting with the Mallet it's not working
the way you solve this is class based so
what's actually happening is you have
impoverished well you say Chicago as an
example you have impover impoverished
areas with a higher density of of black
people what the left does is they look
at the neighborhood see black people and
then think the race is the reason which
is racist they then start saying
insanely racist things but there's also
Latino
Eastern European immigrants white people
living in these areas as well so here's
what ends up happening because the
people who can only see race who are
racist and have always been racist think
the solution of the problem is more
racism they go into a neighborhood that
may be 70 black and 20 white and they
say all of the black people here are
going to get a special benefit so that
we can put them in better institutions
and then their their neighbors their
equals and their peers who are not black
or who are you know Latino or white or
whatever are sitting there holding empty
bags saying What About Us
then what happens when you have people
of different racial backgrounds and this
the state comes in and gives money
literally to one racial group
in these areas I'll tell you what
happens the racial group that doesn't
get the benefit
they they keep engaging in the crime
they typically engage in but they target
people with money so you end up with
other people being like hey this race is
attacking this race all it does is make
racial tensions worse the real solution
is as you're in your analogy 100 people
living on a block you know 80 percent of
or 80 of them are working at the best
Institutions and are wealthy and they
say we want to we want to make sure
everyone's got an equal to opportunity
what do we do I know those of a certain
income bracket then they walk into the
portion of their street where it's a
higher density of black latino for
historic reasons and they say to
everyone there including the poor white
people the poor immigrants the poor
Latinos the poor Asians doesn't matter
what your race is we're here to help all
of you so would it be I think it would
still be a bad idea if Harvard were to
let people in that were poor at a higher
rate with the same test scores maybe not
no it's about letting people in who are
poor with the appropriate test scores
but waving certain fees and giving them
scholarships the idea is if you should
be here we're going to make sure you can
be here just because you're poor
something you deserve to go to Harvard
but if we want to help break the cycle
of poverty we find the diamond in the
rough in these areas and we say you have
real potential and the only thing
holding you back is that your parents
won't have the money we're going to
cover those costs for you that's how you
actually solve these problems and if the
left actually believed they believed
about historical racism and
institutional racism that policy right
there would disproportionately help
Black and Latino individuals you would
not need affirmative action so I can
only conclude either they're stupid or
they're lying the reality may be a
mixture of both yeah yeah I think that's
right I'll also add this part of what
affirmative action does is it recenters
our thinking about the purpose of having
a career the purpose about of going
through an academic institution the
purpose of being admitted to a college
right the reason that Society sanctions
these things the reason Society gives a
person the position of privilege and
esteem that it is to be a student at one
of these universities is because they
believe that that student is going to be
able to contribute and the reason they
have good evidence to believe that that
student's going to have something to
contribute at the level that they're
being given that honor is because of
their test scores because of their
academic history these things the
purpose of social positions is not to
make the person in the social position
feel special for having the social
position the purpose of a social
position is to find what we can get from
other people
what's a social position in this just
like I mean anything uh a job a position
as a student right with anything uh
anything anything that Society carves
out and says this is what this person
does we're either going to hire you if
we're an employer or we're going to
elect you if you're someone running for
office or we are going to give you this
seat at our University if we're
admitting you the whole purpose of it is
this is somebody who if we give this
position to will be able to contribute
to society Society in a way such that
it'll make it better not let's give this
person this position so they can feel
special here's the other thing
imagine there was a neighborhood that
was uh lower income and these leftists
are like these poor people they should
go to college okay for what
go to college for what yeah what what
what what job or career or plan so they
go into this poor area and they say we
want to give you guys college and the
poor guy says this area is working class
industrial Factory we are some of the
best in these areas the amount of money
generated from these factories is lower
than the ivy league areas that doesn't
just because they may make less money
doesn't mean everyone should just be in
college some some like what we want to
do is we want to maximize people's
talents and abilities we want to make
sure that everybody's getting their best
opportunity so if someone is from a
neighborhood that typically is working
class but they clearly show an affinity
for the law we want to make sure that
they have an opportunity to reach that
the left just says we want more people
of Race To Be an institution which just
makes no sense
what they're really saying is we want
less white kids and less Asian kids at
these institutions well it's the Asian
thing for the most part the uh
you know I I've talked to leftists about
this quite a bit and I'm and I always I
always end by saying after they agree
with all of this all right fine have it
your way but you have to be the one to
look the poor Asian kid in the eyes and
say I'm sorry kid you don't get to go to
college because you look too much like
that guy that's their arguments well I'm
sorry that little kid looks like that
little kid therefore only one of them
gets to go to college well I was talking
how does that make sense I was talking
to a friend of mine uh who he's a white
guy who's married to a Mexican woman and
they have a son together and uh he was
looking for private schools in New York
City
and he his son's complexion looks more
like his white fathers than it does his
Mexican moms and they said actually you
know
you you don't look the part like we
can't support you financially and give
you some breaks because you don't look
uh the right color and so even though
he's half Hispanic which would
technically qualify him but he doesn't
he doesn't look Hispanic he doesn't get
uh a lower rate for tuition uh as the
Hispanic kids and so you know it's just
like people are getting fed up with this
I think the affirmative action uh being
overturned is going to be incredibly
popular with the American public I think
a lot of parents a lot of white parents
a lot of Asian parents they've kind of
held their tongue because they don't
want to be called racist by uh their
woke liberal friends
um but these college campuses are
turning into hell holes as well I had a
family member who graduated from the
University of Wisconsin-Madison so I
went to the graduation in May
and some student on campus uh just from
random student got caught using the
n-word it was a white girl who used the
n-word so 10 minutes out of the
graduation two black girls got up on on
stage welcomed by the dean and she
lectured the students lectured about how
racist the University of
Wisconsin-Madison is and how much
progress they still need to make and so
these girls are lecturing the entire
graduating class and the 50 000 parents
and family members that are in
attendance about how racist the
community is and how much University
Wisconsin sucks and they just let it
happen I'm like what the hell is going
on these places yeah well there's a kind
of self-flagellation that every
left-wing institution has to partake in
we're so racist we're so horrible we're
so sorry that type of thing I mean they
almost feel as if it's a kind of and I
shouldn't say they almost feel this way
it is I mean it's just a virtue signal
right it's just a virtue so it's
ridiculous I mean like you spend all
this money going to the school and your
kids graduating and the school forces
you to listen to How racist your your
kids are and how yeah how much the
school sucks so your kids are horrible
people thank you for the money uh we'll
send you a letter asking for donations
take a look at this tweet from uh Aliana
Johnson so uh let's see she is the
editor-in-chief at the Free Beacon
Harvard to turn to essays it says in
email this is Harvard basically
declaring they intend to ignore the
Supreme Court ruling and use loopholes
to keep being racist watch out the email
says Dear members of the Harvard
Community today the Supreme Court
delivered its decision in students for
fair admissions versus president and
fellows of Harvard College the Court
held that Harvard College's admission
system does not comply with the
principles of the equal protection
Clause embodied in title VI the Civil
Rights Act the court also ruled that
colleges and universities may consider
an admissions decisions an applicant's
discussion of how race affected his or
her life be it through discrimination
inspiration or otherwise we will
certainly comply with the Court's
decision
you see what they're saying there yeah
absolutely they're now going to make
everybody right about their race and
then they're just going to choose people
who they think fit their woke ideology
and it's going to be I mean this is
going to be very difficult to enforce
right because I certainly I don't
advocate for lying in any situation but
a lot of people are just gonna lie a lot
of people are going to write their
essays about how like they were black or
they were Hispanic or whatever when they
were white so that they could get into
the institution some people have
actually done that before some people
have done that by saying they're Native
American I'm not sure if you've heard of
it admissions consultant who went on the
CNN interview
he is Indian
and he said he was black so he could get
into Harvard Medical School oh wow and
then he went on and he's become one of
the leading uh Advocates against
overturning affirmative action he said
this is wrong like I should not have
been able to get accepted just because I
said I'm you know I'm black and now he's
an admissions consultant and helps
people I don't know if he helps people
game the system or whatever he does but
he went on CNN he said we need to
overturn affirmative action and has
become one of the leading advocates in
it but well I suppose the question is
how far will this go because affirmative
action isn't just in universities it's
everywhere it's we have the Press
Secretary of the United States of
America is Simply Hired because she's a
black lesbian woman so the vice
president
I think that's an opinion made by a lot
of people who think it may be the case
I'm talking about specific and overt
examples in in the public where they
outright stated like like for for actual
public jobs they actually put in the
descriptions hey we hire based on these
questions
apply basically the Vice President Joe
Biden said I'm going to get a woman of
color like that's it's from affirmative
action well and this is this is an
interesting point right because we're
told affirmative action is good we're
told the concept of diversity hires are
good but if you ever insinuate that
someone was a diversity hire or that
they're in their position because of
affirmative action that's evil wow
affirmative action is good why is that a
bad thing to say Kareem Jean-Pierre may
be the worst press secretary we've ever
seen man at least and I would say she is
the worst In Our Lifetime Jen saki was
really good at what she did she was
really good like as much you have to
like her I think she lied a whole lot
but she played the press That's what she
did really yes she was smart she's gonna
Shuffle back on that bro exactly that's
the job yeah she knows be very smart you
know that I despise it uh I'm not even
like even when it comes to Spicer mcaney
did really really well because she had
the book debunking The lives in the
media that is a fantastic way to handle
it as for she's the worst here's the
thing
she was hired by the Biden
Administration
for who knows what reason
saying that she is was hired for
affirmative action isn't is just an
insult with no as far as I know there is
no formal declaration that they were
seeking out to hire a person based on
these criteria it's a weak argument I
have no idea about it we know Kamala we
know they do it but kamalo is an elected
position so even there Joe Biden saying
I want diversity doesn't meet the same
level no what I'm talking about is in
our schools in our fire departments and
our police departments they explicitly
say race as a criteria that needs to end
if leftists want to be racist and then
publicly declare they're racist and then
when it comes to hiring we have to make
that argument we'll make the argument
but right now affirmative action extends
to a whole bunch of public institutions
directly and overtly where the
government literally allows you to take
raise into consideration for hiring for
public jobs debt should not be allowed
and this should be the ruling to shut it
down I don't know if it will be though
because this is specifically about
University admissions yeah no I mean 100
I agree with all that I think that there
is a difference between mean a job
posting saying we are going to hire
people based on these racial
characteristics and someone saying
they're going to pick a VP based on
those credentials I just think both are
really scummy and slimy and stupid
well I agree with you it's it's
remarkable to me that there are I don't
I I just don't get it are people the
average person is just stupid and
doesn't care
less person is thinks that if a square
peg and a square hole means that it's
succeeded here's what here's here's how
polling works I have a question for you
Sheamus yes hit me actually let me ask
Ian Ian do you think uh universities
should be allowed to reject an applicant
based on their race no all right that's
a one vote in favor of opposing
affirmative action uh let me ask you
another question Ian do you think that
universities should be allowed to uh uh
uh allowed to approve applicants based
on race if it helps bring diversity and
give opportunity to underprivileged
groups bring the best people man I do
not care what you look like or who your
dad was this is how the pollsters do it
you go to someone and say should should
Harvard be allowed to let minorities
into the school to help end equal in
inequality everybody says yes
whenever pulser goes out and says do you
think Harvard should be allowed to
reject a candidate based on their race
everyone says no
you see how that work because if you're
allowing someone to come in based on the
race that means you are rejecting
everyone else based on their race quite
literally that means that for in order
for that to exist two applicants come in
a Asian one and a black one and you say
too many Asians not enough black people
that's how it works one would be
rejected so this is how pollsters
operate and this is how the public
operates the left uses this this
language manipulation gender affirming
care like where did that come from this
is what the affirmative action it's
called racist race-based admissions
race-based hiring do you believe race do
you believe we should have uh race as a
criteria in job applications yes or no
no no no aside from casting for a movie
look if you're gonna do a Netflix reboot
right but I mean you know the way you
look not even that in acting it is yeah
and Bolin has to be played by uh is that
what happened or whatever like I don't
know ambulum is a black girl they didn't
move a reboot and they had and they're
doing they're doing another movie with
like a mixed race woman I'm all about
that but you shouldn't have to well
didn't some like Academy Awards or
something say you have to have like a
diverse or minority group represented as
like one of the top characters in the
movie or you're not going to be uh
eligible for one of our Awards that's
how you know if a movie or not though do
you wanna do you wanna uh take the lead
role in my movie about Shaka Zulu
absolutely yeah
[Music]
I feel like I'm too old for that right
never doesn't matter anybody can play
anything oh my God he was a merciless
dude in a good way I mean merciless oh
my goodness this is the Zulu I mean as a
warlord leader like Genghis Khan style
this guy was one of them is it a
surfboard he's holding that's a shield
those dudes are wild man
what was that what was that weapon that
was like a curved stick with a ball at
the end of it it's crazy stuff dude uh
uh anyway he was like a powerful warlord
but my point is simply
they will they will like their ideology
makes no sense if we're doing a period
piece from you know 1500s Europe they'll
say who cares if it's if it's a you know
a black or Indian person playing yeah
like characters but you're not gonna
cast a Sheamus coggle in his shot
because that would just that would like
that would be racist and stupid right
that would just be racist and stupid but
when you do the exact opposite of it it
becomes non-racist and smart like all
right okay I guess so I thought we were
like bypassing the race thing in 20 2006
I was like man we really have started to
see eye to eye brain to brain
like I was actually getting to a point
where I would just look at people I'd
see their eyes and everything else was
just kind of this gray black white green
blue mesh of color and shade and I'm
just like interfacing with their brain
something happened in I guess Obama
pushed a little bit too much racism uh
subtly when he was in office like the
black kids the black kid and you're like
dude it's just it's not Sheamus is gonna
wake up from the simulation he's gonna
be a black woman why is it why are you
picking on me yes it's always me how's
that picky no nothing he's good because
insinuating you know Ian bringing up
like the AI stuff you know
if we if we do go metaverse Ai and all
that stuff people are going to identify
as whatever they want like Rachel
dolezal if she was in the metaverse her
her you would you would meet her
identifies anything yeah well as a black
woman and she's a white woman well so
you'll you will have like white men
morbidly obese white man who identify as
as black thin black women will do that
and you'll have like you know you'll
you'll have an Asian guy randifies as a
Mexican dude and stuff like that like
people will just decide to present these
ways in in the AI in the metaverse well
you know it's interesting because we'll
joke about people like Rachel dolezal
right uh and we'll talk about how
ridiculous that is but I mean really
race is actually on much more of a
spectrum than sex is yeah right you can
actually be half one and half the other
like if you have a if you have a a black
mother and a white father then you're
going to be half black and half white so
those boundaries are actually not as
well pronounced as the boundaries
between the Sexes are and yet we'll say
because of like some infinitesimal
number of people who have uh confusing
Anatomy or birth defects that that means
that that sex is on a spectrum it's
ridiculous yeah like like Rachel if
Rachel Douglas all is one percent black
then is she allowed under that this is
the interesting question no the the uh
no no
um uh it was a college humor I think who
did this the yes yes the panel of Asians
if you can identify as Haitian yeah so
it's uh it's a it's a full it's a full
Asian a half asian and a quarter Asian
on a judging panel and a guy walks in
who's an eighth Asian and they're trying
to determine what he's allowed to do
it's like is he allowed to compliment
Asian food and it's like yes but not a
physical anyone there who's more Asian
than you that's right then you have to
ask first and then at the very end the
last gag is a guy walking and he's like
my great great grandma was black and
they're like you're black very different
this is The Melting Pot the United
States it's got to be intentional this
rare push for racism has got to be
intentional it wasn't supposed to be
this way man and it wasn't like this in
the early 2000s at all there was the
Arab racism that's probably what really
started it was 9 11 fear the Arab kind
of mentality they got forced on us 2003
was crazy hyper racism dude people were
Banning Muslims and crap 100 Years of
democrat rule in Chicago and it is
extremely racially segregated they have
done nothing to stop it they keep saying
they're doing things to help people all
they're doing is making it worse yep and
and New York isn't isn't as bad as
Chicago but very very similar in terms
of racial segregation and how the police
handle all this stuff I mean during the
2020 Summer of Love College campuses
started having uh they said if you come
back to school in the fall we will have
black only dorms in 2020 they have
segregated dorms but uh because they're
showing how non-racist they are like
it's it's insane we've done a total wait
we've gone
completely backwards and so it's so
let's let's jump to the store because we
were getting a little bit into Ai and I
do have this story uh pulled up from the
GMG Union this is the I believe it's the
Gizmodo Media Group this is big news
check it out and the onion Union our
statement on go media's plan to
implement AI content just days after
laying off Newsroom members ladies and
gentlemen I'm not a big fan of uh
Jezebel Jalopnik Kotaku Deadspin Etc
Gizmodo but uh I stand with them on this
now personally I think it's fantastic if
these people ultimately lose their jobs
because I am a
remorseless and ruthless in the the
left-wing lies perpetrated by these
individuals are horrifying the reality
is a i Jezebel is 50 million times worse
than some random feminist complaining on
the internet they write on June 29th
geomedia informed editorial staff it'll
begin a modest test of AI content on its
websites the AV club Deadspin Gizmodo
Jalopnik Jezebel Kotaku quartz the root
and the takeout
as the unionized editorial staffers of
geomedia organized The Writers Guild of
America East we are appalled by this
news the hard work of journalists cannot
be replaced by unreliable AI programs
notorious for creating falsehoods and
plagiarizing the work of real writers
journalists uh don't do anything dude
they've literally found a perfect
replicas that's right yeah and for lower
cost our newsrooms have spent decades
building trust with audiences sure
introducing computer-generated garbage
undermines our ability to do our jobs
erodes trust in us as journalists
damages Our Brands and threatens our
jobs okay they're firing you though they
don't care about your jobs they don't
care about you now here's what I gotta
say man that's a tough one to read these
people have no trust they don't they
these these org these these news
websites have been sold and over end
because nobody reads them they they
produce an article to get viral clicks
someone will read it and then leave and
not come back they have no core base
that's why they're struggling and
failing Tim cast for instance is doing
better than ever because we actually
have an audience and we care about our
audience we built up trust with our
Audience by trying to be trustworthy
they don't but I gotta say it
if these websites Implement AI it will
be worse than you could imagine because
the AI will be unchecked and it will be
just pulling a bunch of random garbage
on the internet compiling it to a
paragraph that's not real yeah and
people will believe it and where it gets
worse it's not about one website doing
it it's the fact that all of these
websites the AI they get will be reading
the AI articles they write Gizmodo will
AI generate an article that Jezebel's AI
will read it will then compile that AI
article into a new article which Gizmodo
will then read and then make an article
which Jezebel will read you get my point
if the AI models are only learning from
other AI news websites the end result is
going to be a whole bunch of fake news
worse than you've ever seen now I can
also say this
there is a positive possibility
if they do this they are essentially
destroying themselves these people are
getting fired they're losing their jobs
it's the end of these organizations and
the AI garbage content will only work
for a couple years at best so maybe we
say if they want to set a fire that
destroys them why should we intervene my
view is that fire will spread everywhere
on the internet and eventually you'll
see some conservative be like here's an
article from conservative news dot you
know news or whatever that says Donald
Trump does backflip and the source is
you know conservative trends.com whose
source is Fox News and fox saw it on
Gizmodo and Gizmodo wrote the whole
thing up fake from an AI
it will be too confusing if we allow
this to happen my fear it's gonna happen
anyway
so at the very least I can express I
oppose it
but I think it's coming anyway I'd like
to have some of these reporters
journalists whatever you want to call
them on the show these people that are
being fired it's as you were talking Tim
I've started to think of Jesus talking
about bring me your huddled masses
you're tired you're poor however you
said it but bring them bring them
they're they're allowed I think you're
talking about the Statue of Liberty
didn't Jesus say like bring me the weak
among you the the sick the poor
Liberty okay yeah I'm not a Christian
but what didn't Jesus also acknowledge
like he cared for the poor and loved the
poor so I'm talking about man so these
people are they're they're about to be
cast aside into the dregs of society
they're being fired from an already in
my opinion crappy Institution
I think it's now it's time to to accept
like to be there for them you want to
hide them tell their stories no I want
to have them on and and hear them
complain about what happened to them
I'll hire them
absolutely oh boy yeah uh it's the it's
called the Goku method well the thing is
but you gotta understand it's a very
important live lesson when Vegeta tried
to destroy the Earth okay and was
fighting with Kakarot Goku and the the Z
team converted Vegeta into one of their
allies and now he's actually one of the
most popular characters Abraham Lincoln
that's how you gotta do so we gotta hire
them and turn them into good good guys
do you think there's anyone behind the
scenes at these places who have become
disillusioned and actually would like to
work here I'm willing to think there's a
possibility that at least there's got to
be at least one person at one of these
places I I am half kidding but I am
willing to bet a good portion of people
who work there are only saying what they
think they have to say to get by in a
city yeah and if someone came along and
said how would you like to own your own
house have an acre of land to yourself
and not have to worry about this anymore
I'm willing to buy a bunch of them say
sure oh yeah and he's like okay you can
move out to Western Maryland and West
Virginia where you can buy a house for
substantially cheaper than a condo in
New York City you'll have land you'll
have a car you'll have clean fresh air
and no one will will come down on you
for saying that the real Revolution is
the people that are waking up realizing
that careers and livelihoods will be
stripped by artificial intelligence and
a technocracy going to take their power
back like creating their own jobs in
their own communities
that's how it's going to work yeah I
mean look I'm ha look and I said this
before
um when we were talking about another
media Outlet we won't name going under
and I understand this no one here has
technically gone under but there's a
potential for it I hope that these
people find more productive work than
writing lies for a living
well at least hope they have a Great
Awakening I mean I'm sure a lot of these
news networks they celebrate if a coal
mine shuts down or a factory gets moved
overseas to to China or to Mexico or
wherever it may be uh and you know I'm
not excited about the the with AI Rising
I don't I personally don't want AI to
replace truck drivers because driving
truck is a top profession for men who
don't graduate high school or just have
a GED
um you know and so like I don't
necessarily want journalists to lose
their jobs but a lot of these
journalists have cheered on have cheered
other Industries like coal miners
because of the you know
environmentalists uh in the in the in
the journalist newsrooms they hate coal
they hate oil and so they cheer every
time like a pipeline gets shut down or
something like that and tens of
thousands of people are put out of work
but uh hopefully they use this as an
opportunity to be like you know what
maybe I'll stop writing uh cheerful
articles about the these real working
class Americans losing their jobs I
don't think they will ever stop hating
Real working-class Americans to be
honest but here yeah I wish it happened
but it doesn't matter let me tell you a
story right it was uh Brian krasenstein
recently put out a tweet about Libs of
tick tock and a feud ensued and uh he
shouted us out saying he wrote Tim Poole
wrote the most Fair uh and correct
assessment of what happened with the
story it was actually Chris Bertman a
writer who wrote the story up and Our
intention with timcast news is literally
just to tell you what happened I don't
care if you agree or disagree with Brian
krasenstein we've had him on the show
disagree with him on a lot of things
agree with him on some things I think we
had a good conversation you know he's a
liberal guy
Chris Bartman wrote the story as it was
krasenstein tweets he's like I can't
believe it he's like it's it's Tim Poole
who's who's writing the honest listen
maybe that will you know a little light
bulb on for the krasensteins if you are
reading Tim cast news you are getting
our best attempt at just telling you
what's happening we are not trying to
trick you or manipulate you or help
anybody win an election
that's how you get it done
the problem is these people at these
companies like Gizmodo Jezebel whatever
they're they're lying for clicks why
well their bosses tell them to not so
much overtly they say hey you're not
pulling your weight your articles aren't
doing very well so what does the writer
do chases the algorithm to try and
figure out what gets the most clicks
timcast news does not exist to generate
Revenue it exists because we want there
to be some good uh effective journalism
out there be it ilad aliyahu on the
ground in New York capturing that viral
video that took over the internet for
the past week though we're coming for
your children thing or an article by
Chris Bertman explaining
just what the feud was to the point
where Ryan Cranston is like wow thank
you for being honest about what happened
it's not like it's a positive story
about him it's just we're not lying
about him yeah we're not going to make
money off that and we don't need to we
just want there to be a source for news
that does does a good job
news I don't think can be a big money
maker I think it's Gotta like so that's
that's basically what we do I'll stress
this when you become a member at
timcast.com understand that your
membership helps support the news the
writing that we do at timcast.com the
news reports we do and journalists like
a lot on the ground at these at these
marches just filming what they're saying
illad didn't put out a video and say I
can't believe they would say this these
people are discussing he literally just
tweeted Marchers say x fact statement
and then everybody was shocked by it it
created this big hubbub that's the point
of doing good news of doing not good
news but doing journalism right
these people are just they're in it for
the clicks and the revenue you can't run
a business that way yeah I'm also you
know I'm curious to see how these AI
algorithms when they start writing
articles are going to try to test the
algorithm
to figure out what goes viral
that's going to be very interesting to
see and also to see how quickly AI is
going to be able to crack that code and
figure algorithms like this out it's
going to be that that's why I've
described the AI apocalypse as people
walking around dressed like popcorn corn
on the cob turning on a TV and there's
nothing like corn commercials and then
you know you're going on the internet
and like everyone's phone is hit like a
piece of corn and all anyone talks about
is the new coin that just came out and
the reason being
the AI will latch onto something it
thinks is popular force it and then
create a cycle like it will create a
self-fulfilling prophecy of popularity
it'll know like if this article goes up
at three 3 17 p.m it's more likely to
get views if we posted an article about
corn yesterday at 117 and so it'll start
pre-con confluencing these these
behaviors to try and manipulate humans
to be at the right moment at the right
time to see the stuff but I do agree
that it's not for-profit news is kind of
funky anyway it was never really
supposed to be about making money
I don't well maybe it was I guess when
they started newspapers they were all
for-profit extra structure yeah I mean
it was a service early on uh there's an
old newspaper we I was reading at an
antique shop or I can't remember where I
got it from
um it's like a bulletin and the news is
something literally like you know Bill
replaced his front door it was like the
news was literally just like what the
neighborhood was up to yeah and as the
world got bigger the news got got bigger
I bet Bill wasn't happy you know when
newspapers were just about what was
going on around the town of people were
like I don't think everyone needs to be
in my business they don't even know
about that new door it would it would be
like IRS is going to start wondering how
I got the money for a new door it's just
shut it down literally the news would be
like on the front page he would say
John's shoes selling a new nine size
nine model you know we talked to him
about it it's like seemingly innocuous
but this is what mattered and you're
like you're really like oh I'll go check
that out I'll go downtown and you know
see what's up in a way it was a simpler
time but those were also the times when
you'd get a letter in the mail saying
come you're going to fight a war that
you have no idea what's going on about
and you'll likely survive and then you
wouldn't and we ain't going back till
it's over over there now we know what's
going on in the world we can say no a
year 10 years beforehand and change the
course of War as a populist so that's I
wonder though so I I think it's good to
be informed I think it's good to know
about these things but then you wonder
especially at a broad level when people
aren't focused on local issues and are
looking more at National politics how
much a person can really affect I think
knowing more about what's actually going
on in your neighborhood with your own
school board and your own local
elections would probably be way more
productive in the long run yeah like uh
building a balloon and floating a
balloon both are important like the
building of the balloon is the local
structure structural organization but
once you've got that down you got to
learn how to float the balloon which is
geopolitics yeah I just don't think we
have the inflating of the balloon I was
gonna say I don't think we have the
inflation down but well we have the
inflation down
um I just think we we haven't reached
that point where our local politics are
um as together as they should be yes not
enough people know how to build their
own structural balloon and so they're
screaming and trying to grab the one
that's already there and control it but
like you've gotta you've got to build
your own you know
here's what I think
for no reason
I think everybody should move to
Berkeley County West Virginia why why
how come
just cuz just cuz
moved to Berkeley County West Virginia
this is not Financial advice if you're
uh if you're planning uh we we welcome
y'all as neighbors
I'll I'll just say that um Jefferson
County is the Harpers Ferry area and
then just to the West is Berkeley County
Jefferson County is based and Berkeley
County is cringed and we need uh we need
some good neighbors to come and help
make West Virginia great again so as we
are seeking to you know obviously we're
building our studio the reason I bring
this up is because we're talking you
know in terms of local politics people
really don't pay attention and so as uh
I'll give a shout out to A.G Morrissey
because last night we were saying like
where's the action being taken and he
he's not the guy for this in West
Virginia some states and at the federal
level the AG isn't in charge in charge a
lot of this uh the Aging West Virginia
isn't as much so it's not necessarily on
him it's on the D.A but my understanding
is that Berkeley County is surprisingly
fairly woke and so all that really means
is the people of West Virginia
especially Berkeley County who we know
for a fact are not on average lefties
have not done their civic duty and gone
and voted and paid attention to what was
going on at the local level and they
have allowed
for instance uh child drag shows for
children to happen in their jurisdiction
Jefferson County Bandit Berkeley County
is allowing it to take place and I
really doubt the uh the D.A will
actually do anything but you know I got
it so we'll see I think if more people
move out there and morrissey's running
for governor I think he's going to have
tremendous success in the upcoming
primary uh he's I think he's a
phenomenal AG he's been a leader on the
uh fighting the woke issues you know the
state of West Virginia divested uh from
BlackRock before any other state so you
know everybody focuses on how Ron
DeSantis and Florida divested but uh
Riley Riley I believe yeah Riley Moore
the state treasurer and Morrissey uh
they were the first state to divest and
so
um I think he's going to be a great
Governor as well if he gets the
opportunity Riley Moore is awesome man
he's been on the show a couple of times
he's just here a few weeks ago and I got
to say about Harpers Ferry West Virginia
one of the most beautiful cities I've
ever seen in my life a small San
Francisco probably what it was like in
the 1860s right right around the gold
rush time uh it's like just buildings
that have been leveled to the ground I
would love to live in Harper's Ferry
I've kind of got my eyes and my focus on
Harper's Ferry right now and if it's
coming out woke whatever I don't care I
will transform that City I will be there
for those people I want to be part of
the local community and the local
governance
wow what a place to live with the
Divergence of those two rivers it's
beautiful it really is very beautiful
and the real estate prices out here are
incredible
um I know the governor the current
governor and some state legislators they
wanted to make West Virginia zero income
tax and uh if they end up doing that I
mean I I would move here in a heartbeat
yeah property uh property values will
definitely jump if they do that but it's
sad you see this happening in places
like Harpers Ferry where it's like this
beautiful little town it's illegal in
Harpers Ferry what are you talking about
Jefferson County is where Harper's Ferry
is they have specifically outlawed drag
shows oh no that's that's not just
that's not just what I'm talking about
but you Ian you mentioned it being woke
but you'll have these maybe it's not
maybe I don't know but you'll you'll
have these but you know you'll go there
and see pride flags and stuff I mean you
have these like beautiful little pockets
of the country that a lot of left-wing
people move from big cities to and then
start to fill up and hang their Flags
everywhere and but they're allowed to do
that I love it yeah I mean you're
allowed to purchase a place where you
want to it's just ironic because they're
the people who complain about
gentrification and people being
displaced but then they're fine Phil
exactly they're fine filling up these
conservative little areas and pushing
the original culture out I will say this
too because I looked it up and uh
according to West virginia.gov it does
say that the Attorney General is
responsible for state criminal law so uh
playing a critical role with the guard
to save criminal law Prosecuting on
behalf of the state so but apparently
the argument I'm hearing is that this is
going to come down to the County D.A as
regards to having this lewd and
lascivious behavior and public involving
children so my view is just that uh you
know I bring this up one obviously it's
personal to us because we're we're
investing in the area and building in
the area
but uh if people don't pay attention to
their local politics don't be surprised
when Maga Country West Virginia
elects liberal District Attorneys who
who allow criminal activity you know
what I noticed Obama used to do is jog
jog around the city I don't know if he
did it a lot when he was president
yeah and I did used to do that in L.A
you want to talk about getting in touch
with your community jog around the
streets jog around the blocks just jog
by people's houses sometimes you see
them and you wave at them while you're
jogging it's awesome
yeah I'm more concerned about are you
paying attention to who's running yeah
what they believe is jogging not just
who's jogging and uh uh if you are not
voting your local elections don't be
surprised if one day you wake up and
there are you know adults walking around
thrusting their their naked bodies at
children and then when you call the
police the police say da says it's fine
well I'd like to give a shout out to
1776 project pack they've been uh
raising more money than any other group
to help elect uh good conservative
School Board candidates across the
country and they've winning at
incredible rates uh and then also
president Trump just introduced uh a new
policy that he'd like to implement we
allow parents to vote on who's the
principal of your local school oh no
that's great and so like you know what
happens now is like a woke
superintendent in a big you know City or
something like that they are the people
that are trying to identify who the next
principle is but like I think the parent
should have a say in who is in charge of
the each each School across the country
country
well let's uh let's let's do this let's
jump to this next door we got this from
uh Daily Mail take a look at this Google
drops its sponsorship of Pride and drag
show after hundreds of workers signed
petition calling it a direct affront to
the religious beliefs and sensitivities
of Christians
what is this Sheamus
I thought you guys were being oppressed
you thought the war on Christian listen
we're pushing back we're saying we're
done we're finished no I mean obviously
this isn't Christians are one of the the
groups that you're allowed to hate on in
America and as it turns out they're
getting kind of sick of it and they're
starting to actually stand up for their
valleys it's a beautiful thing to see
and I'm very proud of all of these
people for standing up and saying
something because one thing we've said
on this show countless times is that if
you're in one of these positions if
you're at one of these companies and
you're too afraid to speak up the
problem is only going to get worse so
thank you to everyone who signed this
and but I also think we're finally
starting to see conservatives take the
advice that for one I've been saying for
a long time and that's use their own
laws against them it is illegal to
discriminate on the basis of gender sex
race religion national origin Etc so
when they announce they're doing this
this is what I was saying about that kid
the kid in Boston or whatever who wore
the shirt that said there are two
genders and they're like you gotta take
off the shirt it offends people
they should have immediately said okay
we are counter suing for the school to
remove anything referencing Pride
because it offends Christians yeah and
now we're seeing it these Google
employees were like hey you're
discriminating against the space on
religion that's illegal and they what do
Google do I don't think Google cares
about Christians I think they're worried
about lawsuits yeah they'll lose them
dude it'll be like Easter and then their
little Google graphic will be some
insanely obscure Marxist theorists
birthday or something I mean they don't
care about Christians at all yeah oh I
agree with you on that but I think a lot
of these companies are starting to wake
up I think the Bud Light boycott was
incredibly successful the outrage On
Target uh and another exciting thing is
that uh conservatives are not just able
you know we're not just boycotting these
companies now they're taking their
dollars and shopping with their values
and you're seeing marketplaces you had
Michael Seifert on last night from
Public Square the dude's crushing it
he's got like a million daily or monthly
active users tens of thousands of
businesses from all across the country
on his app Public Square and uh you know
Americans are like I don't want to give
my dollars to these companies that hate
my guts I want to shop with my values
I'm going to support a local business in
my community that says they're you know
respect me and respect my values and so
uh it's a good step in the right
direction but like
I agree with what Sheamus is saying you
go on to Google on Easter and there's
nothing but if you go on to Google on
Juneteenth it's the biggest celebration
in the history of the world so yeah or
or it could be like a Christian holiday
and they'll find a way to honor
something else instead it's just it's
ridiculous I want to know more about
this story uh what did Google actually
pull support from they were going to
have a drag show they say Google dropped
its sponsorship of a San Francisco Pride
event the tech giant sponsored a series
of LGBT events across the us annually
and this year the headline event was due
to be a pride and drag show at Beau gay
bar featuring popular performer peaches
Christ
but employees noticed Google removed the
show from its internal events page after
a petition was launched opposing the
event of religious grounds well it
sounds like they did it because the guy
the performer named himself Christ yeah
they're like directly and clearly
mocking Christianity
file a federal lawsuit over the sisters
of Perpetual Indulgence performing at uh
Dodgers yep and it's like if you want to
do a drag show fine you probably
shouldn't have kids there and it
shouldn't be done in the stadium but you
want to bring on people to explicitly
mock someone a group of people sorry
those are your laws you can't do that so
so I suppose a drag show doesn't
necessarily upset Christianity but it's
calling yourself Christ that upset
Christianity well drag shows upset
Christians too but I think in order to
put together an open letter that says
there's religious discrimination
specifically it obviously helps that
it's an open mockery of Christianity
yeah drag shows probably bother
Christians for a lot of reasons but not
as Christians and they don't necessarily
well even even as Christians right like
the Deuteronomy says a man is not
supposed to wear a woman's clothing or
what man's clothing right I understand
that but my point is
if a guy puts out a dress and crazy
makeup and ends on stage he's not
intentionally trying to attack
Christians yeah no that's what I'm
saying I mean the fact that they this
guy was specifically singling
Christianity out gives them the grounds
to say it's religious discrimination if
the con if the company we work at funds
this or sponsors this
I was thinking about Shakespeare a lot
lately because they used to wear drag
the women weren't allowed to perform
weren't allowed to be actors back then
so they would it would all be all the
women would be played by men in drag but
it was widely accepted I don't know how
how grotesque they would get on stage
this is there's a lot of simulated sex
this is culture War winning
this is Google of all organizations
backing off of a pride event and it's
not the first time we've seen something
like this Sheamus actually put out a
cartoon uh today that it's been a very
bad pride month exactly and that's
getting what they've wanted Starbucks
pulled back right yeah and then James
cartoon the woman looks at her phone and
all the all the logos are changing back
to normal but yeah after like a day or
two these companies are are pulling away
from this because regular people are
saying not interested I didn't see all
the companies change their logos from
their normal logo to their pride logo
this this year are you changing your
picture for Maga month I will be of
course yeah I mean everyone on July 1st
everyone's profile pictures have to be
changed to an American flag version but
Sally use your blue check for a little
while on Twitter if you change your
picture yep what yeah careful I've heard
that too or your name
yeah
change your profile picture to be the
same one but with a background of an
American flag you still lose yes change
your profile picture it takes about
three days really get it reverified it
took me about three days yeah you still
get it back but
what do you love more that check mark or
your flags I'm talking about I
got my bio
yeah but we're we're corporate verified
so I think we don't that wouldn't matter
for us they might Fast Track you because
we're we're we're at an approved
organization with Twitter you know what
I'm gonna do it anyway yeah I believe
you're right though Alex that it is a
policy that if you change your name on
Twitter or your profile picture there's
a day or there's a there's a set amount
of time where they've got to re-verify
you and then they don't charge you money
or anything they just need to make the
way it works for organizations
we just give someone verification and
you're verified instantly well did you
see Congressman Wesley hunt and you just
had him on the program he's introducing
a resolution uh in Congress to make July
American Pride month magma and so Omega
month American Pride month maybe got the
idea from your show but uh you know it's
going to be a congressional resolution
and so if anybody disrespects the law
well good hold him accountable June is
American greatness month and so what was
happening was all of these organizations
were changing their corporate logos to
rainbows to symbolize uh God's covenant
to the Earth so it was actually you know
they're they're all Christians it's just
a long game it's a long game
no but you know I was saying this uh for
a while I think Sheamus I think you
should fly a rainbow flag and I think
Christians should March their protests
with rainbow Flags we have to not the
same ones that you need to make it
abundantly clear this is ours you took
it from us you make I would recommend
that you take the actual Rainbow the
full colors uh in God's covenant and fly
that flag so it is somewhat discernably
different but kind of similar the point
being do you really think the left
based on how they operate tribally is
going to defend their use of it they're
gonna they're gonna run screaming oh the
left the left's gonna claim that
Christians appropriated the rainbow from
the lgbtq community they'll stop Flying
the rainbow flag they'll change you
think so absolutely you'll be like we're
totally you you'll respond to them hey
that's really cool that you have a
rainbow that's our symbol and it's been
for thousands of years too stole it but
don't even say that just be like we're
gonna fly this we're gonna fly a rainbow
flag too then when they go in March all
you got to do is when you see a guy with
a pride flag be like hey Christians look
no no no we're not they're like it's
Christoph fascists they're trying to
take the country over and force their
values on like if if you're not
Christians why are you flying God's
covenant flag but it's not the pride
flag it'll be like that's one of the
deadly sins that does it that is
Covenant the rainbow's the symbol of
God's covenant it's a Christian symbol
and has been forever yeah so oh it's
interesting are there seven colors of
the rainbow is that right yeah I think
uh Catholicism
uh yeah virtues Seven Virtues seven
colors
yeah there's seven sins and Seven
Virtues each one has a like like
Chastity and lust are like opposite so
they're just seven Heavenly I would like
to get a prism and uh blast some light
behind me and split it into seven colors
behind me I'm not I don't want to
actually fly a flag behind me but I'd
love to get that rainbow Visage behind
me that'd look cool I just understand
why Christians have given up on that
symbol well you know I think I think
because Christians weren't flying
rainbow Flags around before the alphabet
people took it but but still I mean it's
crazy it's crazy to think that for
thousands of years the rainbow was it
was a symbol of Christianity and then 20
30 years ago yeah 50 years ago really
but you know popularized in the past
couple decades all of a sudden now the
rainbow is a symbol of of Pride how did
it become a symbol of Christianity well
because after the the flood God sent a
rainbow as a sign that he would not
flood the world again okay yeah so it's
like the sign of the end of the storm
just in general the storm is the way of
putting it that's I guess that's the way
it's like a promise specifically in this
instance like a promise that he would
not flood the world again like God's
covenant with the Earth but a lot of
people are upset about that yeah about
what the fact that they stole it or that
it won't flood it again because I get it
yeah a lot of people are like well you
know who am I to question but it's like
bro I will build the boat just let me
know
at the the subreddit Noah get the boat
and it just it shows people doing
horrifying things dude watch any random
like
I don't know World Star Hip-Hop video
out of New York late at night and you'll
just be like it's time to build the ark
is it raining yeah yeah I think we're
passing through the torrid meteor storm
stream again what is it every 23 000
years I don't want to miss miscalculate
things but apparently apparently the
last time the Earth was flooded was when
we were passing through the torrid
meteor stream they call it the torrid
because it's when we are viewing Taurus
the constellation is when they when
we're passing through the meteor stream
and those are the meteors that peppered
the North American ice shelf and uh the
north Asian ice shelter yeah Global
flood and apparently we're going to be
passing through this again or are
passing through it right now December
it's amazing this Confluence of events
how things are coming full circle you
may say it peaks in November so it's
better to have your boat built by then
oh boy yeah let's pray that we don't
strike one of these because it's it's
Madness and Chaos out there but there
isn't a magnetic field you know there's
a repulsive mechanism that Earth has I
think that is is working Synergy with us
as long as we don't the planet off
and I'm not I'm not like a climate
change actor yeah I was gonna say a
whole lot of seconds
clean up the Earth though because
there's a way if we if we knock out our
magnetic field with pollution or
something yeah or like nuclear weapons
we very much it might get hit by uh
outer forces I
let's jump to the story here so uh Matt
Walsh tweeted earlier that uh we're
winning we're winning and that all the
left has left is censorship I believe he
is correct he's correct in this post
from glad it says lgbtq celebrities and
allies call an Instagram Facebook
YouTube Tick Tock and Twitter to stop
the flow of anti-trans hate and
malicious disinformation about trans
Health Care true allies do not profit
from anti-lgbtq hate y'all are losing
it's not gonna happen
sorry the fact that Google just canceled
a pride event shows your CL your cries
are falling on deaf ears
so I'm not going to read the letter
because it's stupid but they're
basically like anybody who says we're
wrong is actually hateful that's what
they've been they've been saying that
forever look at all these people but
it's been there like one thing Alan
oh he's a great actor man well
foreign
Amy Schumer will we have to do it we
have to do it if Amy schumerous I I just
don't think that there's any way around
it at this point boys all right who else
we got here Billy Eisner who's that oh
Billy eckner he just did the uh the
rom-com the gay rom-com bombed nobody
wanted to watch
and and I'll say this too about his
movie Bros just simply put yeah if you
make a movie whose Target demographic is
point zero four percent of the
population don't be surprised when it
sells tickets to only point zero four
percent of the population actually do be
surprised and call everyone a homophobe
that's what he did didn't he that's
right well I don't know if he actually
did it but but it bombed and they were
like it's not fair something was wrong
they're they're they it should work
Dylan Mulvaney's on there believe it or
not oh
it's a cult Judd Apatow yeah
the thing is like I don't think it's
possible for any of these names to
disappoint me you know
she's the voice of Katara in uh Avatar
well what are they what was the letter I
don't want to really want to read
through all of it basically saying they
want us banned for oh for for transfer
for not supporting good child sex
changes
look Healthcare they call it Healthcare
in the letter I understand the position
not everyone agrees that cutting young
children uh to to sever parts of them is
necessarily Health Care they they they
appeal to Authority and say well the you
know AMA says so but my my point the
whole time which has not been refuted by
a single person other than your science
is not real science even though it is is
that you have several studies showing
desistance without intervention is over
60 percent that study needs well also
the Netherlands started doing this more
than one it's multiple studies yeah and
another one started doing this in 1990
basically before I mean not just
basically but before any other country
and they've found that the suicide rate
doesn't decrease so I mean either the
left has to say that Europe's medical
system and particularly the Netherlands
medical system Nordic Europe's medical
system got it wrong and America's evil
grub Capital system got it right or yeah
here's my point for these people if
let's use the lowest possible
interpretation of desistance studies
sixty percent if sixty percent of kids
who are dysphoric receive no
intervention and then go on to lead
normal lives
why give them intervention if there is a
60 chance you will subject them to
something which has a high rate of
suicidality
it literally makes no sense the the odds
are in are are leaning towards let the
kid grow up yeah go at the very least go
through uh 14 or 15 years old should be
the minimum before they even consider
doing any kind of social whatever
because if a child is this fork and you
do literally nothing it's actually
upwards of 98 of kids desist they don't
de-transition I'm saying if they never
receive intervention in any way they go
on to lead normal lives and not only
that but these numbers are from before
we saw the massive spike in trans
identifying youth so this was before
every other kid started calling
themselves non-binary which means now
the desistance rate is almost certainly
going to be much much higher the funny
thing is like I guarantee you not a
single one of these individuals knows
anything about this of course they don't
know anything about anything right about
the assistance Dylan Mulvaney
yeah he did that JoJo rabbit movie Wanda
Sykes
Rosario Dawson is surprising I thought
it wasn't Luke doesn't Luke know Rosario
cool she she was with Cory Booker for a
while Senator Cory Booker like dating or
yeah dating well you know there you go
there you go that'll do it yeah that's a
cult man we got to use if you want to
get through to people like this you
should use in my my opinion Patrick
Stewart's smaller words so how dare you
Captain Picard decisions I think just
blanket confuses people that aren't
really highly intelligent if they hear
desistence they're like they don't know
what that means
um dysphoric that word's too much for
people they don't really so if we could
you can use like simple language like
most of the kids that like child sex
don't get child sex changes turn out to
be not you know they turn out to be okay
kind of thing yeah
um that's a that's good kind of well I
used to get sick what they're doing to
the kids agreed I think uh Chloe Cole
she makes a really compelling case as to
why you should not allow children to do
this you know she went through the
transition process when she was 16 and
regretted it by the time she turned 18
but by by then it was already too late
for her now she has uh she won't be able
to have children and a lot of these
different complications and she speaks
out so adamantly about how this is wrong
and children shouldn't do it uh and you
know we need to take action probably at
a federal level to ban puberty blockers
uh ban these testosterone for dysphoria
for children
um and also we just need to ban the
surgeries and the procedures it should
not happen in our country uh it's it's
wrong and I feel like every single
politician uh you know that's in the
Senate during Congress if a Muslim
country for example was mutilating the
genitalia of the youth every single
member would send sign a resolution
saying it's disgusting it's barbaric and
it's wrong meanwhile here in our country
they're like oh this is so wonderful and
so
um you know I remember about four or
five years ago there was a case in
Minnesota where a Muslim doctor was
illegally mutilating the genitalia of
right of young girls and everybody's
outraged about that but if you do it in
the name of oh the parents wanted it
yeah if your parents brought the little
girl the little girl agreed and the
doctor performed the surgery it's wrong
but but the left is in favor of parental
rights as they describe it it's so wrong
but they were all outraged about that
case why do you care so much
because I want to have children one day
and I don't want to have them grow up
and thinking that they're the wrong
gender because they're not and uh we
can't let this happen amen well I mean
it's it's this refrain we hear from them
all the time whenever you point out
anything disgusting is happening why do
you care so much why do you even know
that that's happening it's like I mean
you can literally make that argument
about any horrible thing that's
happening in the world
um the only way in the argument shame is
to make sure nobody can have it is to
make sure that nobody can have the
artist nobody can care nobody can ever
have the argument
what they're saying is yeah oh yeah yeah
it is it is better that no one talk
about it yeah because if they do the
results all go in the same direction
exactly people clearly people will see
that this is all made up nonsense then
again you wonder how much of this look
this is Hollywood all right how much of
it is these people going I really care
about this cause and how much is it uh
Excuse me yes this is your manager
calling you're going to sign this it's
going to look really great for publicity
all right and yes no we're putting your
name on it okay gotcha boom what does it
say ah doesn't matter it's going to look
good it's going to make you look good
you're gonna be star darling
I think I uh I think I have an example
for you from today yeah take a look at
this from page six non-drinker Blake
Lively accused of cash grab as she
launches the alcohol brand I saw the
story earlier everyone's like yo she
talks about how she doesn't drink and
she's selling booze what what do you
what did you expect yeah like let me
tell you I wake up in the morning and I
drink Casper coffee gonna say you wake
up and drink booze I was like damn no I
drink coffee like we we Blended our own
coffee it is delicious I like drinking
it I would like you to buy it
she does not actually want to drink she
wants you to drink this is what these
celebrities do like I got no beef on her
launching a product she doesn't have to
be a drinker to sell booze I'm just
saying don't be surprised when they come
out to you and they're like for just 10
cents you can save a pet in need and
then as soon as the camera raps they
walk over and she's like you know
throwing the like bringing the cats to
the youth for euthanasia or whatever
like they don't care yeah exactly
exactly I mean it's all superficial
they're all just trying to promote
something so that they can profit
themselves obviously in this instance
they're promoting something which is
unbelievably barbaric disgusting
horrible something that people in a
civilized society would not support and
yet here we are because we are
increasingly less civil with each
passing day but ultimately I agree They
Don't Really targeted laws they don't
know about it they don't know targeted
misgendering
and dead naming of trans and non-binary
people
they're saying that's got to be stopped
yeah like dude
you cannot tell me what I can or cannot
call you
if you want to have an argument about
harassment
there's a block button as a mute button
but I can understand I can understand
there is a line in harassment legally
and criminally speaking if you go out in
public and you're showing somebody's
house or their place of work and you're
insulting them and screaming at them in
demeaning ways the police are going to
say you are now officially harassing
this person you have to stop it of
course or otherwise you will be
criminally charged I agree with that as
it pertains to social media but if it is
an open public conversation where I in
my space my Twitter account I say I
think Ian's name is Ian and he's a guy
and I'm going to keep saying it that's
not harassment I'm expressing an opinion
on a public figure what if someone
chases you down the street and says hey
I'm gonna gay bash you
that's a crime do you think it happened
though it literally it obviously didn't
happen
story is really really sad and and and
you know being one of the signatories on
this it shows you the depravity of these
people yeah I will I will tell you the
story I I feel
there's a lot of people
who will look at say like uh Dylan
Mulvaney and then
the feeling they get from seeing someone
make a mockery of women they then
project onto all trans people and I
think it's really important that when
you think about someone like Elliot page
you should be having sadness in your
heart sympathy and empathy for this
individual who is seriously abused in
Hollywood and became depressed was
self-harming was hearing voices all this
is all from the Elliot page LA Times
like like Memoir story
this is a person who is in deep need of
help
and the problem is I don't I don't I
don't the people who there's no one
there to help these individuals because
you'll either get conservatives being
condescending and rude most of the time
to any of any of these people and then
what happens to someone like Ellie page
can only go to the left and what does
the left do encourages self-harm yeah so
that's why I'm like when we were talking
earlier about like Gizmodo I'm like I'll
hire him yeah like the only only way you
get people to stop doing bad things is
give them an opportunity to do good
things yeah I mean there has to be a
road to repentance yeah absolutely turn
it around yeah I think that
um
people were
showing some compassion towards uh I
guess I don't want to see compassion but
most people have always been against the
trans movement and period uh but people
didn't have as much hatred in their
hearts towards them until they started
coming for the kids
and sell it until they started promoting
hey young you know five-year-old you can
transition genders and we are here for
you and that didn't I feel like that has
escalated so quickly and it's only a
couple years old this movement and maybe
it's been going on behind the scenes a
lot longer but like it's becoming
mainstream the last couple of years and
it's turning people that were like you
know what uh I don't really care what
you do as an adult to uh like I'm
against it altogether the San Francisco
Boys Choir they made a song um we'll
convert their children men's course and
it was I think an example of when
someone gets a hold of a large amount of
power and then misuses it like they had
the trans Community the trans movement
was going strong when that came out it
was like finally for the first time
reality they have a voice they're
talking about it in public it's
mainstream conversation and then they go
and do something like that and piss off
Untold it was not the trans Community it
was like some gay men small group yeah
yeah and it was like 50 guys so what are
they saying they're going to come gay
men are going to come for your kids like
what and they tell what they thinking
exactly in the song that they want to do
they want to they want to take your kids
and bring them to hang out with with
strangers they want to expose them to
things parents trying to protect them
against I mean yeah it's it's it's it's
it's evil those guys don't speak for all
gay people obviously but man what an
abuse what a mistake what a fumble when
you have that kind of opportunity to
create a conversation and it's I I don't
think it was a mistake on their part I
think they knew exactly what they were
saying and doing I think they knew
exactly what they were saying and doing
I think what you were saying it is evil
and um you know president Trump he's
like I don't like the word woke
well because what's happening in our
country it's not just well it's sick and
it's evil what they're doing to or to
our kids isn't woke it is sick and it is
evil and is demonic and it needs to be
called that and it's like woke is like a
friendly word people like that's not
harsh enough president Trump is right
he's like it is sick evil and demonic
and we need to call it out
yeah yep it is demonic and speaking of
which and actually tying this back to
something you mentioned earlier Tim
about elad and the the research that he
was doing in the journalism the good
work he did publishing that video
um and it was a video of course where
people were marching in the treats in
the streets at a pride parade saying
we're coming for your children we're
coming for your children
um NBC tried doing damage control on
this by tweeting the coming for your
children chant has been used for years
at Pride events according to longtime
March attendees in gay rights activist
he said it's one of many provocative
Expressions used to regain control of
slurs
two paragraphs deny the chant even
happened and they said it was just one
guy and we don't even know if he was
lgbtq so it was more than one guy
they're playing drums to it and they're
all shouting it there's a in the video a
girl goes we're we're coming for your
when she says children she winces and
looks aside like even she's having a
hard time saying it out loud but she's
just part of the cult part of that group
and so she goes along she keeps marching
and it's just you know we're at a stage
where NPC really thought they were doing
damage control by saying oh but they've
been saying that forever
yeah
it's crazy that makes it so much worse
this is the apocalypse
another prediction for Chris to the
Christian right man that's all it's uh
come November the peak of the torrids I
love it are they going to cause a tidal
shift or something and the oceans are
going to Bubble Up and just sweep maybe
it would happen in the great flood was
it was a strong gravitational pull that
created a large tide that rolls over the
whole planet at once before going back
down have you seen that old simulation
of what it was like when the moon was
closer to the Earth it's that's what
happened it wasn't the moon used to be
really oblong going around really ovular
around the earth and pulling the water
like I don't know how many thousands of
feet in the air just covering land
masses
uh no we won't flood we'll be okay
where's what was the video how do I find
it
uh I saw it on Twitter and it's just a
simulation a short like 30 or 40 second
simulation uh might be that third video
I'm not sure what that's what's that one
called Mars wet to dry animation and to
be clear if we don't address climate
change it will happen again
what was the story in the Bible during
the apocalypse what happens exactly in
the you want me to break down the whole
the whole book give me a three-minute
elevator pitch because we're going to
Super chats
um like I guess
it's a story where Saint John is writing
Visions about the end of the world and
the different things that he saw taking
place in the The Vision that he saw
basically okay so the reigning
notoriously difficult no the reigning
frogs that's from uh that's from Exodus
I see yeah okay so this is all from
John's Visions yeah so so
there's a number of things it's a
notoriously difficult read
um but yeah there's a number of
different prophecies laid out uh talks
about the dragon sweeping um a third of
the stars from Heaven the the Antichrist
it's there's a lot I call it the
apocalypse because it's that's what
Catholics call it actually instead of
Revelation the the Greeks the word in
Greek means Revelation or disclosure it
means the same thing and ultimately with
the internet was this the video
That's it man that's one of them yeah
this is just how the moon affects gonna
happen again it's gonna happen and when
it was close man
maybe it's not the exact one I've seen
but just imagine if like that the water
gets pulled 50 feet above sea level by
some high gravitational force you could
easily get a great flood yeah we're
we're in a this Earth is in insanely
vulnerable things are happening very
slowly cosmologically but
we're lucky that's the E like it's kind
of it's kind of scary how simple it is
we know the gravitational force will
have this effect on water if some large
body were to pass by close enough and
could could cause I mean I doubt it
because it would have to be as big as
like the moon and be super close but you
know the biggest fear is a melt a large
giant smell like from some sort of
external heat but since most of the
water the ice is already melted uh from
the last flood we're not really in any
kind of danger of another giant flood I
don't think although what happens is
when the ice is removed so like if the
ice caps were to instantly melt not only
is there a huge flux of water now onto
the Earth's surface but the land that
the ice was on top of that's being
compressed down now goes pops up and
when the land pops up Earth elsewhere
sucks down so that's why they say
Atlanta sunk into the ocean the the land
mass not only to all the water melt but
as North America Rose you know Western
Europe sunk and uh I don't know if
there's enough ice on Earth to produce
that that phenomena at the moment
so you're saying there won't be a great
flood no I don't think so there could be
a great steam I mean if comets hit the
earth and cause massive massive steam to
go up and and then it could cause block
out the Sun and then we could enter a
cooling period which would cause massive
amounts of ice which could mess up the
the Earth's magnetic field do you think
Ian that's good the smog and the haze
that's blanketing the entire East Coast
is actually Bill Gates evil plan to blot
out the sun oh is that what it is it
smells like plastic I don't know what it
is yeah it does smell like plastic it's
weird it's so nasty it's even hard to
breathe in here yeah it is yeah I got to
figure something out tonight because
yesterday like last week I lost my voice
and it started getting better then the
haze came in and I woke up and I could
not talk at all yeah I was getting hot
earlier I was like wearing a t-shirt
over my face all day seriously even
indoors we walked in the studio earlier
and you could see the haze in the room
and I'm like what the and we think it's
because we have we have uh exposed vents
because the AC is busted and it pulled
air in or something and so we had to
like tape them up and I'm just like dude
it's so psychotically bad it's gonna be
as bad tomorrow it's maybe a little bit
better but basically so what happened in
John's Visions after all the crazy stuff
in the apocalypse are you familiar
Sheamus well yeah I mean I've read
Revelation but it's a very difficult
read there are a lot of um different
breakdowns of it I Taylor Marshall does
a really good one uh that I would
recommend wouldn't it be funny if you
know like the apocalypse is in November
I mean I think we're in it literally
it's gonna be people are gonna plug into
the neural net and see each other's
thoughts and talk about a great
Revelation not even that like just all
the Revelation is is it prophecy how
would you describe it it's like
predictive uh yeah yeah I mean yes
there are some there there are some like
modernists who will make the argument
that this is this is describing things
that have already happened and it's
talking about Nero but right yeah I I
mean I believe it's prophecy what about
all like is there a time frame for how
long these things are supposed to happen
so there's a book that I've been reading
called trial tribulation and Triumph and
it's a massive text and it sort of
discusses how long
um a lot of these things take and like
how how long the stage is set for the
Antichrist but the basics of it is
whenever you hear people say things like
oh the um you know the Antichrist is
coming next year I mean the events that
set the stage for the Antichrist to like
even take power with the One World
Government forming I mean it's stuff
that would take years
so maybe it's happening yeah well I mean
I guess we're gonna have the mark of the
beast if you believe that we're like
actually leading up to the end of the
world I guess you could say in some
sense the like events that will result
in in the apocalypse are already in
motion but I guess they always have been
is it the end of the world though uh
well at the end of time we believe that
God will end up recreating the world
after the resurrection so there will be
a new world but yeah the world as we
know it so anyways all right so so what
happens
when the world ends like literally like
not Revelation I mean like literally the
point where it's just like okay this is
at the end of the world it's like time
stops the people who still live there
just get like Frozen like yeah yeah and
then like all the good Pious Christians
float up naked to Heaven well so there
would be um a final judgment and then
there's a public judgment where the dead
are all raised and then there's a public
judgment where people see everything
that ever happened and so it's gonna
take quite a while yeah and so basically
God judges everyone in front of everyone
at the public judgment dude so we
believe there's a private judgment when
you first die and then at the end of the
world after the resurrection there's
going to be the public judgment where
people imagine all of it yeah it's bad
enough you know you're worried about
your web history no it's gonna be it's
going to be everything so you're saying
that's gonna be everything the dead race
yeah so so I can see that when they're
trying to recreate people's parents with
artificial intelligence so you can call
your dad after he's passed like that's
the Dead coming back but we actually
believe in a resurrection of the body
like the body will actually come back
people will rise from the grave God will
bring everybody back there will be a
judgment
1500 year old corpse in the coffin will
like reform and like come out of the
ground or yeah I'm not sure how he's
going to do it I'm not sure what God
will do to make that happen but everyone
will return in their body the dead will
be raised there will be a final judgment
and then if the weed is separated from
the chaff and you're either in the new
the new creation the new world and
heaven with God forever or you're in
hell for all eternity I gotta say if
if God's gonna make a point
1500 year old skeleton bursts to the
ground with Bounty hand comes out and
then the flesh starts regrowing and
coming back and then they just like are
back to normal and they're like all
right let's get to it you know what I
mean just make sure it's not that deep
thick because otherwise it's a hologram
or something what do you expect like
just it there's a blank and then the
person standing above their grave I
think it's going to happen on the
Internet it's going to be virtual all
this stuff of like the Dead Rising and
speaking with the dead I think it's
going to be like over and what will
happen is you'll be able to live so many
lifetimes in one second on the with the
neural net y'all like a full Lifetime
and then you'll come back and it'll only
be like five seconds have passed or a
minute and you'll look around the world
and it'll be like time has stopped
everyone in the real world is not even
doing anything as I live an entire life
in the blink of an eye you're still
sitting in your chair just like you were
70 years ago so this world ties I can
see that meaning how time has stopped
well if it's a deep fake Tim will most
definitely be calling it out nobody
calls out right fakes quite like Temple
that's a fact all right everybody want
to go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and go to
timcast.com become a member because
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you at
just about 10 p.m on the front page of
timcast.com you don't want to miss it
it's gonna it's gonna be fun and silly
really not so family friendly last night
we talked about bonus holes
I'll leave it at that but let's read
what you all have to say we have Nathan
pakori says best wishes to Mr bocus my
friends I have terrible news
so over the past seven or so months just
about eight months we have been giving
Mr bocus the cat uh medical treatment
including IV fluids and um
red blood cells uh kidney hormone to
produce red blood cells as well as Ian
got him stem cell treatments
they did not work well I should say it
worked as long as they did so Mr bocus
was a street cat he was uh we adopted
him from a pet from a he was like a
PetSmart or something and we only found
out in December or so that he has a
congenital heart defect and undersized
kidneys likely due to malnourishments
he's a street cat
and so uh his kidneys began failing he
has chronic chronic kidney disease
normally affecting older cats and he's
only four and a half about five now I
believe he may be five years old and um
he was dying
in December I made a farewell video
because they thought he had about a week
left the emergency treatments we got him
prolonged his life this long but uh
something happened
typically every morning when I wake up
we hear yelling at uh I hear yelling at
my bedroom door because Mr bocus is
demanding that we wake up and he wants
us to wake up earlier than we actually
like to wake up and so I wake up and I
open the door he runs in and he wants to
drink water out of the toilet or
something but we give him fresh water he
has he has fresh water but you know cats
and um two days ago he did not wake us
up and so we got to point to the door
and I opened it and he was just sitting
in the living room and I'm like I didn't
think much of it and then yesterday when
he was getting his fluid treatment he
had curled into his carrier which was
flipped over in the corner and was
hiding and would not come out which is
indicative of illness in cats cats like
to go off and hide when they're about to
die
so we brought him to the vet where he
stayed overnight for treatments and it
looks incredibly bad where this may be I
don't even know if I'll make it through
the night his heart is literally in in
failure and he's wheezing and struggling
to keep his eyes open his heart is
unable to keep up his red blood cell
count is half of what it should be his
uh blood urine nitrogen levels are
double what they should be his kidneys
don't work the problem is the treatment
for the for the for the blood problems
causes heart problems and the heart's
already failing so there's nothing we
can do at this point and the vet
actually recommended euthanasia to HSN
no and uh you know there's a lot of
people who think that the appropriate
thing to do is just humanely put him
down
I I don't know that's the right thing to
do because you know the argument is
quality of life is bad and he's
suffering and he's not a dog you know
people like to assign human emotions to
animals it may work for dogs to a
certain degree like when a dog is sick
and scared the dog wants you with it
cats are very different cats are are
little anarchists they actually want to
go hide and be alone so you try and
figure out the balance over the past
couple of days Mr bocus has been trying
very much so to sleep on our laps so you
know we want to be there if he wants us
to be there and I also kind of want to
respect if Mr bocus wants to go crawl
into the corner and you know go out the
way a cat wants to go out I want to
respect that too so we're doing our best
we'll figure it out but thank you for
the Super Chat that's the update on Mr
bocus and um just before we started the
show I I didn't think he was going to
make it to 7 pm his his he couldn't keep
his eyes open his you can see his heart
is going crazy desperately trying to
pump blood and it and it's failing it's
got a clot and yeah Kim brought him back
at about six and uh everyone was excited
to see him because they had the news
already he jumped out of his carrier
went and got a bunch of water ate a
bunch of food but I think the attention
was really kind of pushing him in his
heart so if anyone listening that's in
contact with bucko treat him like a
flower a beautiful flower you don't want
to pick the thing you just want to
appreciate it you know and uh we'll be
there for him it's gonna be okay but the
but let's see him again man the plan is
we're going to get another cat that uh I
believe he's a tabby and we're gonna
name him bocus too
well
yeah you know I uh I hate to think what
his life would have been like if we
didn't adopt him from that shelter they
may have just put him down so you know
the vet said they can't treat him
because the kidney treatment destroys
the heart and the Heart treatment
destroys the kidneys and they're both in
trouble and uh we even talked about
doing a kidney transplant and his
heart's too bad he can't do it if if he
if but this is look a cat grows up on
the street eating garbage and uh he's
lucky to have had as good a life as he
did in fact probably one of the best cat
lives a cat could ever have so perhaps
as they say a candle that burns twice as
bright last half as long and if his
Destiny was to die in the gutter but he
was brought into one of the greatest
places a cat could ever live then he
maximized he maximizes opportunity and
we we appreciate Mr bocus and everything
he did for all of us except peeing on
the floor he did that a lot and we had
to clean it that was the worst part I
wanted him in my room to give him my
warmth and to be with him like my energy
you know to heal him and he just kept
peeing on the floor man like I
love you Buckle but what the dude
like I can't I can't have him peeing all
over my house
it's a wild cat I love the guy but God
damn just peeing everywhere just
wouldn't stop peeing Buckle yeah but
it's because it's because he's a street
cat we love books he doesn't and so uh
you know we brought him here today and
we were upstairs right when we got we
were coming in right before the show and
he walked over to his litter box and we
were like okay this is this is good you
know he's not peeing on the floor but he
stood in a litter box with his butt
aimed out of the litter box and just
peed right on the floor I'll post a
picture I I'm the first picture I ever
took of him was in 2019 I'm gonna post
it on Instagram later yeah you know it
says he didn't we used all the smoke too
it's like just so much worse uh yeah
it's real bad right now the chickens are
all in a special little facility I guess
one chicken got away and ran oh my God
and jumped in the bushes did they Rescue
It entertainment I don't know I saw the
right before I come to the show but I
assume so that chickens are so dumb yeah
but uh I'm hoping Mr bocus has a couple
days left in him and then we'll go find
another cat the idea being that the
spark of bocus he can teach maybe a baby
kitten a couple things before he passes
and
will carry on his his bocus legacy in
Focus too
all right let's grab some more Super
Chips now that you all have heard the
update on Mr bocus
all right
kalishna Bob says any chance of getting
some instant coffee out of castbrew I
don't know I don't know if we can do
that just yet I do know that Casper is
going to have we are preparing to launch
protein I think protein MCT and
um I think we're doing electrolyte and
then I think Chris was uh adamant on us
getting like um lion's mane mushroom
stuff so good dude I do an extract of
that it's so good so we that might I'm
like I don't want to do supplements in
that regard we have like brain blasts
and like a whole bunch of different
things I'm like I just want protein
powder for me that's kind of how I view
it like the coffee we made it's coffee I
like and we want to have a couple things
that I enjoy that I think then we could
sell to other people uh I want to do MCT
and protein because I literally want to
just put it in my own Shaker and go and
skate and then drink it and have it uh
and so you know I'm not going to be
doing any of the mushroom oh you should
try lines man it's pretty cool a lot of
it's psychosomatic you just take it eat
it and you're like wow but I'm it's I
put on what I've read it's one of the
greatest mushrooms on Earth to eat but
we will have more stuff at casper.com
coming up I don't know about instant
coffee though
um I'm not sure about that it seems too
far outside of our wheelhouse yeah it's
also just it's a completely different
thing yeah maybe like we have K-Cups
coming out I'm really excited about so
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
The Wolfman says what should you do if
you've tried several different careers
Sports and hobbies and find you have no
natural talents and don't work well in
the woke corporate paradigm
red balloon at first you don't see try
try again
he has no talents or no natural talents
what is this Alex has a solution look up
redballoon.work it's an awesome new
company that's connecting uh non-woke
job Seekers with non-woke employers if
you ever feel like you don't uh aren't
able to express yourself in your place
of work you can use this job board to
find somewhere uh that will respect your
values and I mean what I love about this
is that uh the woke movement is creating
uh Solutions uh you know the free market
and the the great Geniuses that love our
country are creating solutions to uh the
boycotts we're going to create uh
companies that you can shop with your
values at and then also you can find a a
company that will support your values in
the workplace if you want to work there
redballoon.work yes I like it we talk
about them last night
blave Kai says Ian I love you but watch
the documentary Uncle Tom one and two
before the 1960s the black populace was
skyrocketing upward there were black
factories schools tons of small
businesses and more I remember seeing
the first one it was really really great
Herman Cain dude that guy's story is
incredible hard-working guy believed in
himself accomplished so much yeah I mean
he was great and then everyone on the
left laughed really hard when he died
I've heard an argument that before the
integration of the black and the white
population in the 60s and 50s or
whatever that was uh that they were very
strong enforced black communities that
and they were doing very well and once
the segregation started there became a
hierarchy in these new segregate
desegregated rather the decision this is
the the critical race Theory argument
critical race theorists argue that when
uh pre-segre during segregation the
black community had its own economy and
infrastructure and it was successful
despite the fact that at the white
economy infrastructure was larger
with the end of segregation it forced
the smaller economy into the larger one
which then got crushed smaller small
business owners who are successful in
the black community now had to take jobs
working for white white owned factors
and things like so that may have
happened I don't think that that is a
reason for segregation I don't think
that that's like this is why we should
never integrate races no it's just a
natural phenomenon of integrating you
know two cultures uh of different
economic strata
all right raybert G stanbert JR says Tim
I'd like some advice looking to move to
West Virginia but I remember some places
with bad policies you've mentioned would
like to be near the coffee shop too also
Destiny was losing his mind over Emma
the other day I don't know exactly what
happened all I know is uh someone sent
me a message saying that um he was
watching the video and then like a
minute and he was like oh he's like oh
geez I don't know if I'll be able to do
this yes oh because of what Emma was
saying basically yeah he's not a fan so
we'll say I like Dustin I think it's
fantastic looking forward to having him
back here he's funny yeah and uh he's
he's kind of Ruthless like he just calls
people out it's fantastic
um
so uh what what was the other part oh
yeah West Virginia
um my here's my strategy can we just get
everybody to move to like Berkeley
County and like Martinsburg West
Virginia so we can just
affect policy in a positive direction
that's that's the place to be
technically it's not but it's kind of
the front line Jefferson County which is
uh it leans slightly right but it is a
bit mixed because a lot of DC people go
there to get away from their own bad
policies you'd think would be more woke
but it's actually less
a lot of uh right-wing nut jobs
self-described living on the mountain
and uh you know friends like the the
cops out there they know us they're
they're good people they're fans they do
a good job the uh uh the county
explicitly banned you know these these
adult shows that for people from being
children of these adult performances but
Berkeley County is like the woke area
for some reason so that's where people
need to uh move to and then start voting
to uphold their values and all that
stuff
all right
selmark says there needs to be more
outrage over the fire I don't know what
you do about it I mean we'd be mad but
like we're gonna do build a big 200 foot
wall to block the wind yes yeah and
Canada will pay for it and Canada will
pay for it
it'll be funny if Trump actually said
that that'd be great
cyan Tech says just won the VA Lottery
and got my 100 disability sharing the
wealth thanks for all you do thanks wow
congratulations is that like a big win
are you like a billionaire now and thank
you for your service
the I was going to say by a boat but but
I remember being told that um the joke
is the two best days in a boat owner's
life are the day you buy the boat yeah
and then uh the best boat is the one
your friends your friend owns yeah
but uh you know maybe maybe get a
helicopter there you go those are fun
David Toronto just for bocus really do
appreciate it
we gotta you know I want to figure out
what the appropriate thing for Mr bocus
is when he does pass I was thinking
Viking funeral
what is that like he burned his butt he
sent it out on a boat and light it on
fire fire flaming arrow into the boat
yeah maybe we'll get like a boat we'll
go out into International water and then
put a little thing down and then fire
the little a little flaming arrow into a
little a little boat and have a viking
funeral for Mr Bogus
yeah I guess you could get a picture or
we just dig a little grave for him yeah
you know and put a little whatever you
do we'll get a tombstone made sad he's
an awesome level yeah I've still got
this like belief that he can survive for
a long time
he he that that week in December I
thought he was gonna die he was
struggling to stand up he couldn't
couldn't even get in the litter box
and it was bad he was shaking and then
we got him that medicine and he looked
like he was back to normal I even got
even like three weeks ago I was playing
with a little fake bird and he was
running around and jumping and stuff
yeah he was in great sweaters five days
ago yeah but I will say
two years ago
we'd play for like 20 minutes of him
chasing the bird around and jumping and
doing flips in the air and this time he
made a couple leaps and then laid down
and fell on the side and just wonder if
this air is messing him up definitely
this air right now definitely is messing
up everybody's messing me up and I'm I'm
a human who's taller than the cat yeah
the heavier stuff falls to the ground
and they some Kellen just messaged me
and said that there's uh evidence of
formaldehyde and Benzene in the smoke I
don't know if this is real or not thanks
Kellen for the message though confirmed
according to MJ truth Ultra no I don't
know about that one Rumble and
ciffc.com I wouldn't be surprised dude
this stuff is is is it's gross dude
hurting yeah I could not talk this
morning I was bad it doesn't smell like
like wood smoke no no it's something
else yeah who knows it could just be
that you know the trees burn and then go
up and it collects stuff and creates a
clump of garbage going over the cities
and then washing the garbage from the
cities and everything to us
I don't know man it's bad yeah
let's grab some more Super chats super
chats people are saying like people in
Montana and Idaho and California if I've
been through that smoke too this sucks
this really sucks yeah so
next the Slayer says what is your
opinion on introducing an abortion ban
with a similar life to affirmative
action the ban being needed until a
proper stigma is established and rolled
back that point with a sunset Clause how
long would it take to establish stigma
I have no idea
I think uh abortion should be regulated
at the federal level Congress needs to
enact it not the Supreme Court and my
position on it would be like I don't
know what did Destiny say Destiny said
20 weeks right 20 to 24 but he said when
when
um it's capable of being conscious
basically
I I I I I actually agree uh a decent
amount with that I would argue however
the Consciousness is less material to me
but I understand his point my position
is more of like an authoritarian versus
libertarian thing which puts me at it
should probably be banned after a
certain amount of time federally the
federal government has a right to uh
uphold the Constitution the Supreme
Court probably does need to issue a
ruling on that it does need to be
regulated by conified by Congress
however but it's a 40th Amendment
argument outright the right to life
inequality under the law so well the
left they like to say that Republicans
are radical on abortion but in many on
the left are actually becoming the
radicals on abortion I mean uh are the
radicals they went from pro-choice many
of them maybe most of them from
pro-choice to pro-abortion and you know
when Roe v Wade was overturned you had
these videos of these girls just who
were pregnant taking abortion pills and
mocking pro-life protesters and it was
sick and it's demonic and you have a lot
of these Tick Tock videos of girls who
are pregnant and then they go to a
pregnancy or a Planned Parenthood and
then they say Okay problem taken care of
and the video gets like six million
views and so they are celebrating
abortion now they are the radicals on it
and I think Republicans need to uh turn
the tables on them and start pointing
them out for being the radicals the real
Hydro you know me love him he says Tim
wasn't Tim cast sued for defamation and
from there on you guys have been an
opinion piece and not news incorrect
that is not true uh we
unless I'm forgetting something we've
never been sued for defamation and
um we're uh like Tim cast IRL is an
opinion show but that's because we've we
are literally and overtly an opinion
show if you go to timcast.com what
you'll see is
any segment
involving like me talking or pop culture
crisis or inverted World those are
labeled opinion because they're quite
literally opinion commentary shows and
then news are labeled something else
this has nothing to do with defamation
lawsuits and has everything to do with
standards in journalism
you'll notice that say the New York
Times or USA Today or Washington Post
Washington Post is all the time they
publish opinion pieces and don't label
them opinion that is a violation of
standard journalistic ethics timcast
news does the opposite news is labeled
news opinion is labeled opinion
so uh yeah we we our news is news when
ilad films a video and just writes
Marchers chant we are coming for your
children quote that's it that's news not
opinion that it's a video of it
literally happening
Anka says y'all should have a show
that's just Hannah Claire reading the
news as an anchor I think that would be
a regular watch for a lot of people we
have discussed such a thing
we're just waiting for a free domistan
to uh to get finalized the real Hydra
with another one he says Tim much better
watch but bro get a sapphire crystal
watch such as an Omega or Rolex and you
won't worry about it breaking when being
active that is a good point so
um I have a guard watch it guards a
great company they put these commercials
in support of American values and that
actually is sapphire crystal and it's
amazing it's a self-winding one it's got
a little wheel in it so as you wear it
you move around it spins winding up its
spring so it just keeps running and it's
got a really awesome face and then I
also have this one uh this is a Holtz
current watch and I must admit
the longest time I was like watches why
would anybody wear a watch these days
smart watch I get but why would you wear
regular watches for the time when you
have your phone and then
I actually I was like you know that's
nice I'll get a watch seriously there
are more circumstances where a quick
glance at your wrist is much easier than
pulling at your phone clicking the
button and putting it away and there are
circumstances I found in my life where I
can't be pulling out my phone you know
and it's just it really is interesting
there are circumstances where it's like
I'm playing my video I'm playing a video
game for instance I was playing Final
Fantasy 16 and I'm just looking up and I
go like this boom time and I was like
that actually really does work better
than if I'm gonna check my phone I gotta
pause and then pull the phone out and
take a look and put it back I Like It by
the way did you confirm if you're on
story mode I am not on story mode I am
on action mode I'm not gonna buy it I'm
I'm enjoying it really it's uh
C plus B minus yeah so I'll tell you
what my concerns are with it
the time jumps
yeah that's about it other than I'm
having I'm having a lot of fun with
other diverse characters in the game
no actually no it's like it's all
British people it's all just white
British people weird yeah and um
yeah it's basically like
The Crusade is like it's like Middle
Eastern people versus British people for
the most part I mean look I don't want
to spoil well it's it's not so much that
but everyone's British everyone has a
British accent that's so weird yeah I
don't know I like the game I'm having
fun playing it actually is a a bit of a
blast uh I like the gameplay mechanics
I like old school RPGs turn based but I
know that that's not been Final Fantasy
for a minute or whatever so yeah we're
talking about Final Fantasy 16 by the
way everybody yeah yeah I don't think
anyone would mentioned that but oh okay
yeah Final Fantasy 16. but that's what I
like about the watch like if I'm playing
I can just go like that I'm like I got
the joysticks and I'm like what time is
it okay there we go it actually does
work out really well especially at the
casino when they don't let you uh bring
out your phone when you're sitting
around watches do work also you could be
talking to someone and go uh-huh look at
your watch it's fantastic A friend of
mine has uh sunglasses I'm probably
gonna end up getting a pair of these
that have an augmented screen inside
that plug-in to your phone which you can
keep in like your backpack or in your
pocket he says he loves it yeah I had
one of those uh 12 years ago it's called
Google s apparently they're good now
they're good now yeah
you can play video games on them and
stuff I thought you're gonna say plugs
into the back of your brain or something
not yet let me give it a couple years
yeah and then yes it will let's grab
some new uh Super Chat uh vosh says
you've never heard of gold frap ride a
white horse Strict Machine Oola great
music Bad politics I absolutely know of
the music of goldfrap yeah but just
because I see the name goldfrap doesn't
mean I assume that Allison goldfrapp is
the person from the music group gold
frap though it makes sense that's why I
said who is Alison goldfrapp you know
but yes uh those songs were like 2001 or
something season two early thousands
late 90s yeah I like those songs
old school
zizik says Greta tunberg went to Kiev
and met zelinski today to discuss a
pressing environmental issue saving the
endangered German Leopard is that for
real I know she went there I saw those
videos but like was it really about that
because Mike Pence also went to Ukraine
oh yeah how about that dude I'm sorry
deep State Millennials are just split on
supporting War you're not winning us
back over on this one you needed to stop
Ron Paul 20 years ago they didn't do it
now you have a whole generation of kids
who are online and heard some old guy be
like why are we going to War and why are
we butting to print money and then they
were just like that's a good point now
we're on our 30s and you're like why are
they voting for Trump because we agreed
with him because he made a bunch of
points that were good that's the guy
they should have censored but they were
way too late
you guys you gotta stop the guy from
planting the seeds now all the all these
kids who grew up on the internet and
heard that anti-war message it's
actually a combination of it was
liberals against Bush they wanted to win
and then it was Ron Paul around the same
time everybody opposed to this stuff and
now a whole generation opposes it Mike
Pence going to Ukraine that's endearing
himself to no one yeah he's not gonna
get any votes off of that
we'll grab a couple more here
Robert Sunderland says Sheamus's humor
is so dry tonight even another flood
couldn't wet it but I was straight full
of beans tonight oh my gosh extra
ecclesium what is that extra crazy
vanilla Solace outside of the church
there's no salvation
and then he said God wills it base days
of course of course
all right
Roger Robert Roger says uh wait actually
that was a it just jumped on me there
was a there was one for Sheamus Robert
Roger I thought it was Robert Rogers
asked that one too where did it go
this is what I hate about YouTube okay
it was um Matthew fettig says Sheamus
I've never been a religious person but
you being on the show has slowly
convinced me to give it a chance we'll
be looking for a church for my family ah
dude I'm so glad to hear that look at
this guy he's very happy converting
people on this show well thank you for
giving me the platform but uh yes please
seek out a a good Catholic Church in
your area but make sure make sure it's a
good one because let me tell you there
are some where you will get uh
I would say some less than sound
teaching well so this let's uh like if
that if the church if they offer a
traditional Latin Mass there even if
that's not the one you go to like that's
probably going to be a good one we gotta
grab this one last Super Chat Laura
Loomer asks Tim what do you think about
the DeSantis campaign press secretary
using a burner account named Max to
attack Trump supporters exactly is that
true or anything like this yeah you
gotta look this is it is it confirmed
though well because I've seen some
there's reports and Loomer has been
doing a phenomenal job on exposing this
and people want to write Loomer off but
uh she's right a lot more than she's
wrong and she's been doing this a long
time and so there actually is an audio
file that
um Luma released comparing this
Anonymous account Max's voice to
um Brian Griffin's voice who is Rhonda
Sanchez's press secretary and I'm not
saying it's definitely Brian Griffin but
the voices are similar uh there's a
weird connection but between Brian
Griffin's previous job uh for a group
called The Maccabee uh task force I
think I think the most compelling thing
was um an email was sent about Rebecca
Jones and then a minute later this
account tweeted out the actual footage
that had been received 100 but I don't
know if it's confirmed that's why I I
don't really have much to say but
there's time stamps on it so like Jeremy
Redfern who works for Ron DeSantis
governor's office he received video
footage uh of you know Rebecca Jones and
her son and then a minute after Jeremy
Redford sends an email saying thanks
confirm we got the video max Nordo this
burner account who allegedly some people
say works with Jamie Redfern he had this
video out one minute after and so at the
very least it could be that this
Anonymous Twitter user has access to the
DeSantis team or something like that
yeah some people are saying it's
operated by the entire press team some
people are saying it's specifically I
think we got to be careful got to be
careful that I want to see proof yeah
you know here's my thing
it would be very very easy for them to
delete that video they put up where they
lied about trump super super easy they
could just delete it put up a message
being like we shouldn't tweet it out
sorry about that and that and that but
they won't do it and so that that's the
wall I'm at I'm like all this stuff
wouldn't surprise me but uh we'll wrap
it up there because we're gonna have a
members only show coming up in just a
few minutes over at timcast.com so go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member and if you remember for at least
six months or you sign up at the 25 per
month level you can submit questions and
actually ask us and our guests questions
so that'll be a lot of fun and uh not so
family friendly you can follow the show
at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast Alex you want to
shout anything out
go to Donald J trump.com buy this
t-shirt not guilty who knows how many
more indictments are gonna come they're
going to do everything they can to stop
this man but it's an awesome t-shirt it
says 45-47 not guilty Donald Trump's mug
shot and uh staying with djt right on
Seamus Coughlin I have YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we release a
cartoon every single week we released
one today all right it's a super funny
one I was very happy this one actually
took two weeks to animate it was a
little bit of a little bit of a longer
video and more visually descriptive so I
think if you guys go over there you
check that out you're gonna like it I'm
Ian Crossland follow me at Ian cross on
anywhere on the internet and when you
follow Alex on Twitter it said Alex
bruceowitz good to see you again man
thanks man thanks for being a part of
this grieving process for me tonight I I
got a little emotionally overcome it
happens I love the man bucko you're in
my thoughts and prayers I love you guys
and uh let's move turn this over to
Serge dupreya
you say my name incorrectly every time
what is it it's uh it's dupriya but it's
on on dupriya dupriya dupriya thanks I
thought it was Dupre Dupre the first
time I met you dupriya Serge dupriya
anyways I'll get it right uh I'm
search.com on the internet uh that was a
good one yeah bucko's a good cat I feel
bad about the guy but uh he'll go to a
better place anyways see you guys later
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out